no are you ready
uh yeah just
okay we'll open up the public hearing uh
house bill 1583
and hear from the prime sponsor
representative hogan
good morning sir
thank you very much i'm representative
timothy oregon it represents stratfor
county district six um the towns of
durham and madbury and durham is in fact
one of the larger towns in the state
which does not have a state liquor store
even though
the private
location might be profitable thanks to
proximity to the university of new
hampshire but the uh madbury the lee
circle store is just like
a few minutes down route 4 so um
so if you need wine or spirits uh and
you have to be in durham it's not you
don't have to drive far to get them and
i'm uh
like all of us i'm sort of a shareholder
in the new hampshire state liquor
outlets um
one of the 1.4 million or so
shareholders so i'm
not a large consumer of uh weiner
spirits but i do like want them to be uh
profitable which is what my bill is here
for is it's too fairly
it
was too unnecessary and
i'm arguably unconstitutional
restrictions on our state liquor stores
so it'd make them a little more
profitable by first of all by letting
them serve the public one more day a
year
and also by giving them a wider choice
of locations
so the stores will still close on
thanksgiving christmas but if this pass
the bill would eliminate the closure on
easter i mean i suppose they could close
on easter if they made a business
decision to do so but they wouldn't be
required to
you know thanksgiving and east
thanksgiving and christmas are
well almost universally um observed on
dates which don't change from year to
year i mean there's a few people who for
one reason another refuse don't observe
those dates but um
you know
um even though christmas the secular
christmas elise is always december 25th
although there are some religions who
celebrate christmas on some other day
um
thanksgiving is a pretty much well
purely secular holiday i mean i guess
insofar as you can never totally
separate church and state
um always observed on the fourth
thursday in november so
everybody knows when those are coming up
whereas easter somewhat differently
because it moves around the calendar
somewhat randomly i mean there is uh
and it's probably
only secondarily a secular holiday
although i'm a big fan of the easter
bunny and the gel easter eggs and all
that sort of thing but um
it's a
life not to get off into the weeds and i
don't dress as my written testimony but
basically
the holiday's supposed to be the first
uh sunday after the first full moon in
the spring but uh different churches
have different ways of calculating that
it's not the same as like when the
so-called astronomical easter is that's
why it
wanders all over the calendar like that
um
so that's anyway the existing law
actually doesn't even give a definition
of easter though i guess they've been
closing on the so-called western easter
which is what the roman catholic church
and most mainstream protestant
churches observe but
and
then actually the more probably the more
the other thing which is probably a
little more significant is um
it eliminates the prohibition on
locating churches within 200
locating stores within 200 feet of a
church
chapel or parish house
which well this is actually for for new
stores any existing stores that are
can stay in place um but
the liquor commission should be free to
locate the stores wherever the best
available location happens to be and you
know there is uh
there isn't necessarily a surplus of
good commercial real estate in the in
this in new hampshire
most of the
commission's
newer stores are freestanding i guess
they say big box my written test one
that's not quite what they are but
they're larger stores located on you
know fairly spacious lots with ample
parking and landscaping
um
so they don't and um the newer stores
also tend to be built on well-traveled
locations the outskirts of the town and
that's also where churches like to
locate new churches
so it's easy to imagine a situation when
existing churches property might have
but a desirable site for a state liquor
store and i think the commission should
be able to build stores at those sites
so they should basically have the same
rights as any other
retail tenant
also aside from
those stores you know sort of those
suburban locations on the
highways leading and out of town
such as for example
the one i might visit the most often is
the one on route 9 and summer's worth on
high street um
they um and they're still occasionally
building on strip malls like
the store that i mentioned which is
close to my home the lee outlet that's
built in a
strip mall and
which might have storefront churches as
tenants and also
also um there's still a place for state
liquor outlets in downtown locations
where all sorts of enterprises including
churches might exist within that 200
feet radius so i just think this is an
unnecessary restriction i don't
think there'll be a plethora of new
stores being built in churches because
the liquor commission is uh does like to
be a good neighbor and you know they
and they choose locations that don't
conflict with the other uses and
community but i don't think in every
case that is necessarily a bad thing for
a state liquor store to be next to a
church and certainly in any case they
should be
in the property where they have the most
traffic going by which they can get for
the best price etc so they shouldn't be
when they're competing in the commercial
real estate market they shouldn't be
artificially bound by a restriction
which doesn't apply to any other
retailers so that's um
that's basically my bill and that's why
i introduced it and
i'd be happy to answer any questions
great uh representative bartlett has a
question sure thank you mr chair um can
i just ask you what the motivation is
behind this i mean what decided what
made you decide to bring this forward
um
well first of all
um well first of all it started there
was a thing with easter which doesn't
really have a set definition like
although i guess they go with what you
know the church churches do calculate
years in advance and um
i really can't explain how they picked
those particular sunday instead of
another and then also i just
felt like you know i don't
i don't i'm not a big drinker i don't
use that often but i think you know the
stores first should be in the best
location and their main job
is to make a profit for the state of new
hampshire and also just in general i'm
somewhat
dubious about giving churches
too many special privileges they've been
asking for a lot of them
lately i've been a judiciary for example
just dealing with um you know
whether churches should be uh you know
bound by emergency resolutions and i
certainly appreciate what
churches do but i'm not sure if they
necessarily
not sure this particular protection and
of course not all churches even object
to being next to liquor stores most of
them
most denominations do allow people doing
to certainly allow their
members to drink within reason and
there's somewhere even uh alcoholic
beverages are part of the uh part of the
ceremony so
thanks
veteran burritos
representative greeson okay
why aren't liquor stores permitted
within 200 feet of a school
um well
that uh
well that was like i figured schools
i guess schools are like uh different
from retail i think churches uh
israel churches um are different from
schools and this doesn't interfere with
the church and the school
that may create a certain amount of
danger especially since there's uh
children often most schools have chil at
least some children who have to walk to
the location and i just um
follow up
you certainly can you certainly can put
it in with the schools what the
what the education you maybe have to say
about it or not i don't know but thanks
for the question remain clear thank you
so churches don't have kids
uh well they do yes but that's uh
i mean the people in every any type of
organization
have kids so that's um
yes of course they do but that
and
representative burroughs
thank you mr chair i'm representative my
question is it says that the commission
can could enable liquor stores to be
open on easter day if they make that
decision would all of them need to be
open
um you well we do have a represent the
liquor commission um i mean i think they
make it on
i think they they make it on a i think
they make it on a case-by-case basis
there's some that aren't even open on
sundays but you know where you know
and of course they have uh right now
they have
staffing issues like any other retail
outlet i've i noticed they're always
advertising for for clerks so they also
may not have enough staff to cover every
store seven days a week
um
follow up for the question um do you
think that they're going to be problems
i understand the bill it says that it's
optional for employees to work but right
now
retail stores or across the state are
having problems finding employees do you
think there'd be pressure on employees
to work on a on a religious what is for
many people a religious holiday oh i
can't answer that i
the best of my knowledge it's uh
no worse than in any other retail outlet
in fact i mean
in fact from what little i know i do
have one friend who worked for the
liquor commission over years and he
seemed he seemed happy with his job but
that's like a very vague anecdote so i
don't think it's any better or worse
than any other retail outlet and most
all of those
typically do stay open on easter sunday
so you you said if i understood the
crate you said there was a danger for
kids walking by a liquor store
is that is that what you said or did i
misunderstand you oh my may have said
that i i just
i just sort of felt there's issues
putting a school next to a
liquor store or even any other type of
large
large outlet so that's uh that's
something i just felt like
that was just sort of a
decision i made i was trying to make the
bill like
more palatable to the to the committee
but um i
that maybe
i mean you may want to also allow them
to locate it near the schools too so
okay
representative burroughs again
quick question um representative um when
it when churches are not allowed to to
um i'm sorry liquor stores are not
permitted to build within a certain
number of feet within um within a church
does that include synagogues and mosques
um yes i believe the law
well it's certainly uh i certainly
should say that but i think the law
refers to of course i think it's
something like
places of worship uh which would be any
religion and so yeah that's those laws
have always been the
professional knowledge always interpret
including you know all all houses of
worship and all forms of religions thank
you
see no more questions thank you very
much
uh chair we'll call on aid moore from
the liquid commission
who's
neutral
good morning mr chairman good morning
and committee members my name is aiden
moore i'm the legal coordinator for the
state liquor commission
and we're here just to offer you some
additional information as you consider
this bill
and that the
commission not opening the stores on
easter
is really not really a religious
consideration on behalf of the
commission it's really a business
decision
that the commission allows
people
to be with their families on what is
often considered by many a traditional
family day
and
so that is a significant part of the
decision making of course it's written
into the law that easter is a day that
the store shall be closed
i think it's important for you to know
that
sunday is a voluntary work day
for commission employees
under the collective bargaining
agreement
that exists with the state
and if this law were to pass
i believe and i cannot anticipate
exactly what the issues might be but i
think there would most likely be
some
grievances filed
under the collective bargaining
agreement uh by state employees so
that's
a very strong possibility
so we um
and it's important i believe for you
also know i believe it's listed in our
methodology is that none of the
commission's stores are located
currently within 200 feet of
any
religious facility or school
and i'd be happy to take any questions
from any of the committee members
so i'm looking at i assume this is the
current law
and if if it were true that we
removed easter i guess
um
it doesn't require you to have to be
open on easter if we remove it from the
statute right
that's correct
so you could
help those state employees or
where they if the state employees don't
want to come to work you just say okay
well we're not going to open up for
easter
well i um that's correct mr chairman i
think
what the commission is
feels that the current law as written is
something that we work with very
successfully
and don't necessarily
see a strong rationale to change it
which does not mean we oppose the bill
we do
well i would say that uh
it seems a little awkward that we just
pick easter and not maybe passover or
other
religious holidays and i would certainly
defer to the wisdom of this committee
sir
on your question and and would you also
agree that that pretty much all the
locations you know that we're not really
looking for a big expansion
going forward that uh let's maybe i
guess maybe some marijuana stores but
uh
that that we don't plan to have a big
expansion so
this most of the statute is really not
not a big issue because there's not too
often removing liquor stores to at this
point or opening new ones
well in some cases um
there may be some contraction in the
number of stores based upon a number of
factors
so
i i would say i don't think the
commission has seen an expansion for a
period of time
fair enough representative
thank you mr chairman
um mr moore
might this
change uh cause other
folks of other
ethnicities a problem on their holy days
i'm not sure i um say if we have a a
person who celebrates ramadan
or
uh
different different holy days and we're
just
selecting easter as a christian holiday
might this cause problems if they're
if they are scheduled to work on one of
their special days
i think it's the other way around yeah
i i think what makes uh this
uh representative i'm not sure i could
probably
reasonably answer your question i'm not
sure with the
other religious holidays celebrated by
other religions
i know that
in in the construction of this statute
the legislature appears not to have
mentioned them
by
by their name
i think what makes this uh somewhat
distinctive is that it intersects with
the easter is
usually
always on a sunday
and the sunday is a voluntary day for
commission employees so as was mentioned
by um i forget who in the committee uh a
number of those commission's stores are
not open on sundays simply because
there's no demand for that and employees
are not required to work
it is a commission's business decision
to open keep open stores
that have a high profitability
on sundays and it is a
an area where an employee is offered the
opportunity to work and many choose to
work on sundays
um but east where easter is specifically
listed in the statute
the stores are closed on easter
thank you sir
well
representative greeson
just this is just information that
the
muslim holiday
of uh ramadan is not a single day
and so uh whereas easter is a single day
and always on a sunday so
just like hanukkah is not one single day
either so
but passover is
correct
okay
oh oh yes
representative
um
thank you for coming and testifying um i
have a question about i mean part of
this bill um references relative to the
locations of liquor stores
uh i represent the city of manchester
and uh there have been a lot of closures
and a lot of you know larger liquor
stores being built in the city and it
seems like i just have a question about
your rfp
for
property owners that want to you know
have a liquor store on their property it
seems like there's one
individual that
owns
properties where all the liquor stores
are in manchester
can you
is there an rfp
process to
for individuals that own properties that
may be suitable for
stores to come in and just say this is
like you know i would like to have a
liquor store on my property
thank you for your question
representative
i would be
i must tell you i do not know that
process i certainly know that the
commission
has a team of individuals who
evaluate
um locations uh for
their potential profitability
and uh
so i would i would be uh
doing you a disservice if i speculated
on how that works but if you'd like i'd
be happy to put you in touch with
someone at the commission who could
possibly answer your questions yeah
because i often i have some questions
about that um
for the question i think um
i had another follow-up but all set
thanks thank you
i guess we're all set thank you thank
you sir anybody else would like to
testify in household 1583
saying none
i will close oh we have the sheets
i have eight uh this oh this is the
online blue sheet
um i have uh two people opposed
uh
tom blizza
from center harbor and
and catherine
catherine uh piernell
from wolfeboro a member of the public is
also opposed
okay with that now i will close the
public hearing
this is the online there was nobody in
favor
nice to see you
some of the properties they do buy
but especially in
urban environments
where
so
they'll look there sometimes they
rental property at a higher value than
it does today and sometimes they get
kicked out saying you're not paying us
enough
yes
i'm happy to provide
because there's a
for
you know there's a significant amount of
um
i'll
when the same lady gets up time
i did
do you think the chances of that first
i was actually kind of surprised
your is
is
generated
sorry i couldn't answer your questions
christmas
uh
let's open up the next hearing
uh house bill
16 13
and
do we have a prime sponsor
hi
good morning
then you are
good morning i'm lisa post
post okay
yep thank you i want to thank the chair
and this committee for the opportunity
to
introduce house bill 1613 establishing a
limited farmer's liquor manufacturing
license
um this is a constituent bill and that
person is not here today so i do have
someone to substitute to
represent that person
so this bill
excuse me
gives farmers the opportunity
to
ferment distill blend age and bottle
liquor other than wine
in this state produced from fruit
vegetable herbs and other products grown
on his or her farm in new hampshire with
at least 65 percent of the final product
grown from
produce made in new hampshire grown and
made in new hampshire a limited
manufacturer's license may sell the
liquor it produces to the commission for
resale in our state
no liquor manufactured blended or
bottled in this state by a limited
farmer's liquor manufacturer licensee
shall be sold or delivered in this state
in any manner which is inconsistent with
the provisions of this title
each limited farmer's liquor
manufacturer distilling less than one
thousand cases of liquor per year may
sell at retail at its facility for
off-premises consumption of any liquor
any of its own liquor
each retail sale shall be limited to one
liter case
or less per sale no limited farmers
liquor manufacturers
shall sell more than 12 9 liter cases of
liquor to any one person in a calendar
year
a limited farmer's liquor manufacturer
may provide to visitors at its facility
samples of liquor for tasting
samples shall not exceed a half an ounce
and shall not be provided to any person
under 21 years of age
notwithstanding paragraph three no
limited farmers liquor manufacturer
facturer sell shut sell
sell at its facility any of its liquor
to on-premise licensees
each limited farmers liquor
manufacturers shall maintain records and
prepare reports for the commission which
shall indicate the sales made under
paragraph three and shall pay to the
commission a monthly fee equal to eight
percent of such sales on or before the
tenth day of the month following the
sale
the commission shall adopt
rules pursuant to rsa
541-a
relative to the report of liter liquor
manufacturers under paragraph five
excuse me under paragraph six
each limited farmers
liquor manufacturer
shall have the right to transport the
liquor
its manufacturers blends or bottles in
bottles or other closed containers to
the state border for the transportation
and sale outside the state to holders of
a united states basic permit issued
under the federal alcohol administration
act
this limited farmer's manufacturer's
license
we are asking 500 for that license
what this will do what this will do for
our farmers is
is by by having them able to
distill liquors
with locally uh sourced ingredients
whether it's from their farm or another
farm in new hampshire
will bring them additional revenues that
they dearly need most farms in new
hampshire small farms make no more
profit than ten thousand dollars a year
so this would greatly help them
to keep their farms this encourages
consumers to visit farms driving
incremental tourism throughout the state
which means gas
restaurants things like that hotels so
it's it's a
it's a big boon for us and we
see with vineyards in our state we bring
people from out of state
to come up here so this would be the
same thing
um
this creates more demand for crops grown
by farmers it increases
visits to farms for those
people who don't have families and go to
a farm to see
you know the animals and things like
that this brings a different
feel to the going to the farm and
getting to view what the farmers do and
how they operate and
they get to taste um
get to have a taste of of what they
produce
from distilling
and
the reduced fee for farm-based
distilleries
will lower the steep financial barrier
put in place by the state that prevents
the majority of family farms from
participate
in this growing small batch business
even when we were considering
the 1000
some odd dollars 1 692
which is the normal license fee um in
talking to the farmers they said it's
it's just too costly for them so that
that is why we are asking because these
are small batches and they're not going
to make a lot out of it
so the other
the other
part is that
i realize this is liquor and that
there's been some objection to it in the
past however we do
um small batch for wine so this is very
similar and wine is also a 500 fee so
it's not making a different class of
you know
of cost
the farmers will also be able to turn
their loss crops into a usable source of
income and help keep the family farm a
part of the new hampshire landscape
which is so important here because if
the farms have to sell and houses are
built we lose you know the bucolic
nature of new hampshire so i hope you
all will support this
i'll take any questions and after we're
done i'd like to
ask that you call karen gribco who is a
neighbor uh speaking uh off
excuse me this is karen grib co a
neighbor of the person who put this bill
forth and she is the sole proprietor of
maple lane farm
great thank you are you willing to take
questions
absolutely representative terry
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative post
being someone who's fascinated by
numbers and how they're calculated and
selected i'm wondering if you can share
with me or give me any insights
into
how the
number 65 65 percent line six in the
bill was selected
and also on line 17 that sample should
not exceed one half ounce
could you give me the rationale behind
those two numbers how they were
determined
they were determined by ols
they were determined by ols in in a
conversation
we had to
make
um
come up with a number
and
was
because
you have to have bottling and paper
goods and things like that and in order
to really try
to make it a farmer's bill using crops
we felt that 65 percent was the right
mix
another question would you be able to
share with me any
documentation uh conversation
with ols i'm trying to get to the
thought process here
do you have access to that or is it just
all verbal
it was verbal there there may be some
that is in an email we went back and
forth on this several times we were um
obviously starting with the 100
fee
that the person that the farmer wanted
to start with and then
in that
in the discussion of how to build this
spill came out that we should
have a certain portion
of
farmers produce
um and and so the numbers were thrown
around sure just to be clear i'm i'm i'm
i'm i'm incorporating house 65 sorry
uh how 65 and one half ounce were
arrived at
so thank you for any insight you can
provide thank you very much thank you so
so uh the half ounce is current statute
in sampling
in other distillery
legislation
um i i would say that
the idea of tasking the liquor
commission on calculating the 65 percent
um is
pretty close to impossible uh for them
to to do that that's really we don't
want them to be doing that so my
question to you is
not just wine we actually do it for beer
too we have nanos
okay
would you be overly offended if the
committee just simply
created a lower license because i agree
with you the license is very high
and that and we had and but it wouldn't
necessarily just be for farmers it could
be for anybody
who wanted to do a small batch
and would you be overly offended we
amended this bill to do that
i would not okay
okay great
any other questions i think oh we do
represent immaculate uh yes thank you mr
chairman three very quick questions
number one i assume that any of the
alcohol consumed at this market is only
a sample
you can buy it but you can't drink it
there
secondly none of this will go through
the liquor store
thirdly i can't get any of this at my
local bar the wildcat tavern
just i just put that it just correct you
can't sell it at all okay correct
however there is there is a tax that
they do have to pay eight percent
yeah yes revenue
polio yeah um my question is uh
there is a uh a distillery in canterbury
um and they do use they source their
ingredients from new hampshire
is this the same license that we're
talking about or is this just basically
for farmers in farms
well this bill that we put forth is was
for farmers hoping that we could get
this through but
the chair just suggested that this be
for all folks and i'm in total agreement
of that okay thank you
great thank you very much
thank you for having me today and
can co come up next
but ted you want to thank you i normally
would have another wrap because i have a
reptile oh okay that's fine thank you
the process will you always give reps
you know
thank you so okay so uh and then and
then yes then you want the karen i have
that card next yes okay
so uh representative uh brody desai
please
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
to the committee for permitting me to
speak for a brief moment i'm just gonna
be very quick i mean in light of the
chairman's you know his uh proposal of
how to amend that
changes what i was going to say this uh
this morning a real brief but
i was just going to mention how new
hampshire has allowed you know micro
distilleries to enter into our economies
over recent years
new micro distilleries like tamworth
distilling and mercantile have created
jobs in grow new hampshire's economy
these micro distilleries produce maximum
a maximum amount of liquor each year and
sell it on site or through our local new
hampshire liquor and wine outlets
consumers can shop locally for their
favorite spirits and small business
owners safely fulfill a growing market
demand the goal of house bill 1613 would
be to allow farmers to do this very same
thing just on a much smaller scale
farms
farms will be allowed to produce up to a
thousand cases of liquor per year and
may sell it for off-site consumption and
it will neighbor it'll enable our
farmers across the granite state to tap
into a growing market and grow our local
economies i spoke to one of the previous
prime sponsors of this legislation
representative howard perley it's my
understanding it sponsored a similar
bill a number of years back and he told
me one of the concerns was creating too
many licensure classifications and that
this could end up increasing costs for
am i mistaken mr chairman uh we have so
many licenses uh i wouldn't think
another one really much of a difference
but that's that's interesting to hear
that we have too many when i spoke to
him yesterday he said that was one of
the previous concerns that he had heard
that they didn't want more that they
were like you know having having less
classifications and less layers of these
licensures would be um you know but i
was going to say you know um
farmers do cover some of the cost of
creating this well you know what was
theoretically the original house bill
1613 which i'm speaking to my
understanding the committee is going to
make a very favorable changes to it
which you know i'm more than happy to
see but um they'd cover some of the
costs and the state would obviously have
to cover some of the rest you know any
excess costs but i would view it more as
an investment into this growing and
booming sector of our economy right
there's there's a number of um farms
that would be able to enter into this
you know these micro distillery kind of
uh market and to really be competitive
and to really
help a lot of uh you know employ a lot
of local people so in my opinion i think
the state should promote this kind of
economic innovation you know using our
free market right we're just enabling
people to enter into this we're enabling
people to be innovative like a lot of
these micro distilleries have and this
has kind of become more it's like the
you know we've seen a lot of the micro
you know vineyards a lot of the micro
breweries and now these micro
distilleries and they're really um
there's something that get people out
very excited there's something that
bring people to you know a lot of
tourism areas like wolfeboro and so i'd
like to be able to see some of the local
farms in my district be able to take
advantage of being able to uh produce
you know a limited amount of liquor each
year and sell it off site with that i'm
not going to remain open to any
questions because there's other people
who know a lot more than me who'll be
able to make clarifications so but i
thank you for permitting me to speak
this morning thank you
thank you for coming
chair will call on karen gribble
thank you mr chairman and the committee
for allowing me to speak on
house bill 1613.
my husband and i own maple lane farm in
limeborough new hampshire
and i work with
with the maple guys
buying maple syrup because i have a
home inspected state inspected kitchen
and i make maple brittle and i buy my
maple syrup from them
and
what they particularly would like to do
is
is try making maple whiskey and there's
also
heirloom apple trees on the property and
they'd like to make apple brandy and
just explore other ways of
utilizing their product
new hampshire has a history of
encouraging entrepreneurship supporting
small businesses and supporting
agriculture
and it's under the spirit that we ask
you
to allow
the micro distilleries
we're
i know that a lot of the growers are
primarily looking to use their own
products and their neighbors products
and kind of keeping things very local
and supporting this and
you know one of the ways you might think
like how is this going to attract people
and the monadnock region we have a
really
strong
support for local businesses and there's
a lot of
airbnbs and small bed and breakfasts and
other types of small hotels and their
guests from out of state
they want to experience the new
hampshire way of life and they always
say
where can we go
to
see
how life is in new hampshire and so
they're always
giving them recommendations to go to
small farms and other small businesses
they're not interested in going to the
big commercial places they want to go
and talk
to the person making the stuff or
growing the stuff to find out
how we live
that was really it's really kind of
funny to me having a business that
people come and want to know
how i live and what i do and then they
have dreams of living my life like you
know martha stewart or
something you know because i have
chickens with colored eggs and they go
this is so cool and and i know that
several of the people that have stayed
locally that have visited us have bought
homes in our area and
it i think it's just good to diversify
what people can do and sell on the
stands and
for the most part um
i know that we've all we're not buying
things from outside of the state to sell
at our small farm stands we're we're
buying things from our neighbors and
promoting local things and this would
just give us another thing to use our
product line and
and another tourist
information place to come
and
that's basically all we want to do is
try to use local things in different
ways and
and have fun with creating something new
and different and
i'd be glad to take questions
uh see oh that's representative
burroughs
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i'm not sure you can
answer as i was hoping representative
duchess
might have answered it but um we don't
know how many um farmers or other people
are going to take advantage of this so
my question is about the cost to the
state to monitor the safety
of
these products
i
i don't know i know that there's a lot
of local interest but the costs are
really prohibitive and i just think
something like this would make it easier
for them
to um to try things and i just don't
know how much it would cost to
administer i don't think
i don't know i'm thinking it wouldn't be
that much different than somebody with
um
with making making wine having a small
winery and i know that a lot of them
attract
big crowds and i don't know how you can
monitor that i'm not sure if a micro
distillery is going to attract that many
people all at once
follow up i was really referring more to
the safety of the product
you know to um
safety standards for for alcohol i'm
thinking moonshine and
back in those days
um
i don't really know i just know that
everybody that has
that manufactures anything on their farm
has to follow state rules and
regulations and health things and i
don't think that you know they're going
to take any shortcuts in making this
they're going to be really careful with
sterilizing bottles because they've
already they're already doing it and you
know we we all have to have the safe
handling
classes and certifications and state
licenses and
and we all know what we need to do thank
you very much
thank you
thank you uh
chair will call on charlie post
hi good morning my name is charlie post
i live in leinbrough new hampshire as
close to the mic as you can
willing to get so that'd be great there
we go
my name is charlie post i live in limbo
new hampshire i am a recently retired
executive from
a food national food production company
got a deep understanding of
production something that people really
didn't talk about before but supply
chain and retail distribution um
i think the key to this i'm here to
support bill 1613. um the the i think
the key to this
opportunity for farmers is that they
can't sell to
very easily there's a very high barrier
of entry to sell products to
grocery stores to the state liquor
stores and other retailers it's it's uh
it's a challenge because of the cost but
they can attract people to their farms
and operations and sell products
so one of the ways of doing this is to
add value so they're not just selling
corn or milk it's a value added product
that can be more profitable
and that profit makes farms more viable
i think we all remember that when the
pandemic first started
you know you could stand in line forever
at market basket and wait to get in or
you could go to your local farm and get
milk eggs and some of the supplies you
needed we need to keep that strength of
the family farm and the local farm in
place and this is a way to do it to do
it generated to generate a new revenue
stream for them
you know you've heard about uh how it
would help the overall economy in terms
of um
uh tourism and people attending uh
attending farms and seeing farms and
coming to new hampshire and traveling
within new hampshire
to see how farms operate i think it's a
good opportunity
i really like the idea of lowering the
barrier of entry in terms of the cost of
the of the fee that can be prohibitive
to a very small
farm that uh you know only
yields uh
profit margins of ten thousand dollars a
sixteen hundred dollar margin is is
significant
i think i think it's important that
you know we separate this from uh
from other farm operations it's much
like much like wine distribution or wine
production small batch wine production
there at the
at the farm and
i realized there's a lot of regulation
around that and safety but those those
matters are usually handled now
i i think it's also important to
recognize that they would be using local
ingredients uh you know how you
calculate the percentage you know i i
think it's important that that you you
do use locally uh sourced or locally
produced items um on the farm but i i
really support this bill
and i think it would be a great
opportunity to strengthen you know one
of new hampshire's great resources the
family farms
great
thank you very much thank you uh chair
we'll call on uh marie schmidt
schroeber
thank you to the chairman and thank you
to the board for hearing us on
this bill i am a landowner and a
consumer
and
my name is moritz schmidt schweiber get
that for the record
um so i am very much an advocate for the
state um
grew up here part of my youth and came
back recently and i'm so glad that i did
when i witnessed what's happened in all
the other states so um i just find that
new hampshire should really be very
open-minded
and get into the game
and make it up even playing field so
that um
you know consumers can come up here
and have a lot of options um
and to get access to uh
distillery products on a small
farm basis is something that uh it's an
experience that i think people really
will um take advantage of and it will be
great for the state
so i know we're limited on time so um i
i don't have anything else really to say
on it
thank you great thank you
uh
chair we'll call on drew klein from
josiah bartlett
thank you mr chairman and committee i'm
drew klein from the josiah bartlett
center for public policy we're the free
market think tank in new hampshire and
we're here to support this bill um we
think giving opportunities for small
businesses is fantastic it's the way
legislature should go but i would echo
the chairman's comments from earlier
that probably a better way to do this
would be them in the bill to just have a
general lower tier license that's not
segregated for farms that would create
more opportunity in new hampshire not
less if you were to have something like
this though i would make a couple of
suggestions as has been noted the 65
figure is just unpoliceable
um there's no way to do that and there's
no public health or safety reason it
doesn't hurt new hampshire economically
or in any other way to have it be you
know 60 or 12 percent it doesn't matter
you don't want to hamstring the
businesses because um
whether it's a local farm or a local
small business
they are going to source locally
that's just the way these businesses
work
but contingencies happen so a hail storm
can take out we had this just last year
a hail storm wiped out a lot of apples
so you might have to buy apples from
across the border so you just don't want
to have that percentage in there that
would be a problem um
and uh otherwise um
i think
the other thing is a concern
is um limiting
um this sales to no more than 12 cases
to any one customer in a calendar year
that's just kind of a record-keeping
thing that would be i think you know a
challenge for small businesses and um
you know if you have a
uh
i know when i help out local businesses
whether it's a local bakery
we try to buy stuff and give to friends
as gifts and this sort of would get in
the way of that so i don't know that you
want to police that and regulate that
and force that record keeping on them
that's it
representative abel has a question
yeah yes thank you thank you for your uh
testimony um
would you be able to suggest either now
or subsequently some some way that we
could amend the 66
yeah
so that it would be clear
if we what what we were doing but we
didn't have to be that precise sure i
could come back with i mean
again generally i
i think any percentage is going to be
impossible to police i i just think
that's the bottom line
um but and to rub rose to your question
about moonshine as somebody who grew up
in western north carolina the
capital of moonshining
if you want to depress moonshining you
pass bills like this that make it legal
for farmers to sell stuff i mean
moonshine was moonshine because it was
illegal and heavily taxed and it was
black market so this is what brings it
out of the black market and makes it
legal and safe so
you you drew a question
representative i'm trying to anyway so
you guys can do it i would like to
interject before you speak
the liquor commission is that's not
really what they're doing they're not
you know
if you're worried about moonshine
that's the atf right okay right now
everybody here before we even start
about a new hampshire license you have
to first get your federal license with
the atf and they're the ones who are
going to worry about that right i'll
withdraw a question i was not trying to
disparage moonshine oh i know anyway
thanks for the
clarification thank you all right thank
you
uh and last but not least aidan moore
from the new hampshire
liquor commission uh is opposed to the
bill as written
which i assume that means it can be
fixed
everything in commerce can be fixed sir
again for the committee's reference my
name is aiden moore i'm the legal
coordinator for the state liquor
commission
and we are opposed to this as written
and i think to ask answer some of the
questions about 65 how that figure came
up i think the original draft of the
bill that we saw when we first prepared
our fiscal worksheet
had 100
of the products
which we thought was
completely unenforceable
and it is now at 65 which we still think
is unenforceable
there's just no way for us to to measure
it there's no way for us to police it
um
so
we
as as you know for those of you who have
been on this committee for any length of
time the state liquor commission is
extremely supportive
of new hampshire manufacturers
the commission
extends great consideration
to our wine manufacturers
our liquor manufacturers to try to get
their products into the state liquor
stores
and support them
um because they realize what an
important source
these products are to the consumer in
new hampshire
so the commission is completely
supportive of trying to help a new
hampshire manufacturer
in this case
we don't believe
that creating a new license specifically
for a farmer
is probably the
best approach i i think our suggestion
would be
and possibly mr chairman we could work
this out in a subcommittee at some point
is to look at an approach that creates a
tier of sorts
for the committee's benefit the beverage
world beer the beer world has a
tiered approach
great
we got a lot of coffee going to be be
purchased
this week
so beverages have a have a tiered
approach as as you mentioned mr chairman
a business that is interested in
becoming a an entry level beverage
manufacturer can obtain a nano brewer's
license
and hopefully their success
causes them to move into a
larger
beverage manufacturer license
same with wine manufacturing an entry
level wine manufacturer
in new hampshire
pays a fee of 100
but it's often tied to their production
levels
as a
the fee is lower as they're an incubator
once they've kind of crossed out of that
incubation period
we would look at their production and
say now it's time for you to move on to
a
different license type
so we would think that that
approach would be
realistic to possibly bring here to the
liquor manufacturer
especially
um
for the farmers
if that's where they would like to go
but we would not distinguish them as a
farm
that we would look at them as a
manufacturer period and
some of the considerations that
may
be worthwhile
deal with where the product would be
sold so for example a liquor
manufacturer in new hampshire can sell
products to people who come to visit
them they if they sample it
and like it they can sell it to them
right there
so
the
i forget who mentioned the point but yes
the entry level requirement would be to
get your federal license first
uh but then also we would have some
questions about what
how this would be sold
so for example we would not want to see
products sold
at a farm stand
where you're rolling up and you're
buying your corn and your tomatoes and
two bottles of whiskey
we would want to see a
facility that is a commercial facility
where the public can visit where the
commission has the ability to visit and
audit and create perform the services
that are required to make sure the
license farmer's market would be okay
barmy the farmer's market
farmers might well liquor manufacturers
can can now sell it a farmer's market as
well so that would be
extended most of the provisions that you
see in this bill
dealing with
records and things of that nature are
exactly what exists now in the liquor
manufacturer license they've just been
added to this bill
to um
to
ensure compliance and and the fact that
they
are following the same standard
so
we believe that this uh
bill as written is
not the best approach and we certainly
would look forward to working with the
sponsor and the committee to try to find
a
better approach that
we could follow
great
representative bartlett
thank you mr chair um i'm not sure that
that you can answer this mr moore but um
do you happen to know how much a federal
license would cost that they would have
to apply for and obtain first
uh thank you for your question
representative i i do not know that as i
could get that information for you if
you'd like
i think that'd be really helpful for the
subcommittee certainly thank you
thank you very much
having no more cards on house bill 16 13
is anybody willing to testify see none
we will close the public hearing
okay
so kate fry uh from new futures was in
opposition to 1613.
okay
you know what i didn't even forgot to
pop this on here
uh
what is
um
today
i said i'm gonna flip the script here
and ask you questions ask ask questions
right
i guess
i guess people ask me that all questions
all the time that's true
okay
all right we'll open up the public
hearing on house bill 1556 and hear from
the prime sponsor
representative barry good morning
representative barry good morning and
it's a pleasure to be here i think this
is my first time and
maybe last time in front of commerce who
knows
um i have i have the day before the
committee
hb1556
which um clarifies let's say a um a
point of dispute over the necessity for
two points of sales systems
uh for those operating um
uh brewpub lice licenses where they sell
they sell um
food and drink
as well as
at a distillery or a brewery
i was approached by the brewers
who said that
the they were
that this rule was being enforced upon
them
by the liquor commission that they had
to have two point of sales systems um
separation from for tax purposes from
when they sold to take home and when
they sold for on-premise consumption
um
as many as you know that that's not
necessary these points of sales systems
are very sophisticated the reason why it
was being enforced was because there's
two different tax rates
it's very easy to program the
appropriate tax rate for what you're
selling
so
liquor commission
contacted me and said well this is not
being enforced
so i circled back up with the the
brewers i said you guys just make me put
something forward that's not a thing and
they were able to cite multiple
instances including yesterday
they contacted me um that this is being
enforced it's not clear from liquor
commission what is
and what it should be so my goal here is
to codify in state statute um that you
can use one point of sale system you
still have to collect the appropriate
taxes there's just no need for multiple
transactions the state's going to get
its money anyways let's speed things up
lower costs and
and reduce some bureaucracy i also
submitted to
the committee an amendment was another
amendment that was i was asked to bring
forward i'd ask that the committee kind
of consider this in a separate manner um
i'm not i i obviously support the
amendment i'm sponsoring it but um
it's considered as a separate as a
separate piece and it would extend that
to food stores who opera
also operate
a preparation site
with a point of sale
system so you have some of these i
believe there's somebody here to testify
to that effect but you have um you have
these these stores where they'll have a
food preparation or for a food kitchen
on one side like a convenience store on
the other
and once again there's no point to
having two different transactions if
it's not necessary
but that's the that's the purpose of the
bill it doesn't have a fiscal note
because there's no cost to the state it
won't change any of the revenue that
we're collecting it'll just make life a
little easier if you want to go and
have a pint and maybe purchase a
six-pack
no questions
all right
uh aidan i don't see a card here from
you i'm sorry
oh you do have a question
do you have a copy of the amendment
i do not have a copy of the amendment um
i emailed the amendment to the committee
i believe
maybe yesterday
i can reafford it
its amendment
0282h
it adds i can read it since i don't have
copies of it it looks like uh
representative johnson is going to take
care of that for me
but basically it adds um it adds another
section says any licensee who operates a
food store with one preparation area on
site may use the same point of sale
register as as the licensee stores for
all transactions
so it's the same thing just expanding it
out a little more and once again i ask
that the committee
consider the amendment um and not not
say tangentially related same concept
but in a different area other than a
brew pub
we do have another question
representative weston
uh thank you mr berry for coming in and
representative barry for bringing us
this
i just am curious about why when i go to
the grocery store
and i order a lobster
live it's um i don't have to pay tax but
if i have it steamed then i do
but i go through the same checkout
procedure
so how does that relate to what you're
doing here with the preparation site
versus not so you're actually making the
the argument um right if you steam the
lobster it's a prepared food then you
have your meals and room tagged meals
and meals meals and room stacks tacked
on at nine percent um
and the the point of sale system at your
local market basket is sophisticated
enough to know the difference and
collect different tax rate um so this is
just clarifying that these facilities
these brewery these breweries that have
the exact same capacity as you just
described with your lobster
can use one point of sale system just
like you do at market basket for your
steam lobster i've never thought about
that but that's a great way of looking
at it
uh representative johnson do you have a
question so i got the amendment coming
for a copy for all of us she's printing
it out now great thank you
um see
no more questions for him that was easy
all right trip to concord get
accomplished i'll see you guys later
so aidan i don't have a card here from
commissions
the commission has no position on the
bill sir
i'm happy
yes i do have a question or two
i guess it starts with the
random enforcement
of this
in-house rule uh that it probably never
went to more rule making that that
this division that uh
when the auditor shows up he expects
separate point of sale reports
uh i would i would probably suggest sir
that the
looking for the records is what their
audit would be looking to accomplish how
much product was sold clearly a beverage
manufacturer has the
need to report to the commission how
much it sells for the purposes of
calculating taxation beer tax correct
and
i think the commission
supports um
the notion that today's point of sale
systems
are sophisticated enough to be able to
break down sales
and
to provide information
to the commission
when requested
so can you put out a bulletin or
something do we really have to do this
by legislation can you put on a bulletin
and just
clear this up once and for all so
i'll be happy to speak to the chief of
enforcement and the commissioner
to see
how we can clarify that
good i look forward to hearing from
from the chairman on this issue because
it just seems insane that it's
randomly enforced and
and which tells me it's like one auditor
makes a stink about it and another one
doesn't
um i i think i would
um
disagree with that characterization i
think there's an intent to apply
a standard uniformly across the state
there's no
advantage
to anyone certainly not to the citizens
of new hampshire
to have
policy made on the whim of one person
and the chief of enforcement oversees
the
regulatory and audit function
and has worked very hard to ensure that
there's consistency in the application
of the law
so
i i think if if you would like and if
this is a bill that is going to go to a
subcommittee of course we would be
able to appear at that and provide you
with information to answer your
questions that
may not
i may not be able to provide to you
today i'm i'm shocked you weren't
prepared to explain why this
he was here yesterday
uh you weren't prepared to
uh come in and tell us why
this bill exists
oh i think the sponsor did that no no no
yeah and i would i would probably say um
i i
would repeat my desire
information that the commission desires
to have a uniform approach across the
state fair and consistent
and that that's what we enabled to do
enable uh that's what we endeavor to do
uh on a day-to-day mission and i'll be
happy to have the appropriate staff here
to
answer any questions
and especially if there's a
possible mischaracterization of
something to try to clear that up
oh
okay
because why because i have to say i did
make a couple of random
calls to different uh
manufacturers
and most of them were shocked and never
even heard of this policy
that is not that it doesn't exist it
doesn't exist
that they had to use separate point of
sale systems
i believe i believe that
this may very well have to do with
um
whether a better beverage manufacturer
has an additional license
a beverage manufacturer has a license on
its own to sell its products
beverage manufacturers also have under
the statute the ability to apply for a
second
on-premise license
so depending upon how that business
is put together
how it's organized what the facility
looks like
um
may very well play an important so
you're saying this is this so if i it
was true i did talk to someone who had a
single license and never heard of it so
this would never come up this only comes
up when
they have multiple licenses correct
okay but we'll make sure we have the
appropriate staff here to answer all
your questions sir thank you you're
welcome
any other questions
thank you very much
i have two more cards uh joe greene from
londonderry representing himself
are you here for the amendment then i
say you see yeah okay
thank you chairman hunt and members of
the committee i am here uh to support
the amendment
i
run
a convenience store and food service
entity
we actually have a few of them in the
state of new hampshire
and
this has presented customer service
issues in the past
having the
conversation
with our enforcement
scott dunn
going through the process of trying to
ring up
a six pack of beer per se
at a food service pizza or deli
those
transactions cannot be done in the two
separate entities so
this is what i was told
i wanted to have
them run up in one register and i was
told i couldn't i would only have be
able to ring it up in the convenience
store part of the
of the store
although
my company owns
both
the the deli pizza and the sea store so
i think there's some confusion i guess
even from the last speaker of
if this is enforced or not again when we
try to go out and and have this happen
we were told that it it's not possible
at this time so that's why i am in
support of this amendment because it'll
clarify it it'll make it very simple and
i think it would be um to everybody
that's confused they'll identify it
properly
so you have more than one license you
have an on and off premise i have off
premise
it's just an off-premise license so it's
either way it's still a take away with
the food then right
but then
it's an off-premise
license but one part of the store is
like a classic convenience store right
and the other one would be is say take
out deli that has no tables in it that's
correct
yeah okay
it's it seems simple right but then when
we went to do it like nope you can't do
it this way well i know myself i once
one time i was i went into a
a
convenience store that also had they did
have two tables
and and i tried to open a beer
and he said no no you can't do that
right you have to leave very carefully
take everything and leave
but um
so and this was many many years ago
before i i actually knew the difference
between an on-premise and off-premise
license yeah think of it if you wanted
to get a sandwich okay and you you said
you know what i want to buy a pack of
beer too you literally have to go to the
different registers instead of one point
of sale i mean that that's that's just
been the way it's been for a long time
so this this like i said not to repeat
myself this will really keep it clean
keep it black and white and nobody can
question whether it's a gray area
because right now it sounds like it's a
big gray area
right well
if i had a
i know an on-premise licensee
pizza joint
that sells the beer
the question is is that obviously he
i can't leave with that beer
right
so
okay we do have questions
representative johnson
just so i can make sure i understand it
your pos systems
either one of them could do
all the transactions
and but you have but you're told that
you have to have two
so you could set one of your pos systems
up so it could ring up
the different tax rates for the
different items like your sandwich that
you bought at the deli and then your
beer
you could bring that up into the
different right categories with the
right taxes
and there would be no problem in one
system
i could but i was told that i i'm not
allowed to right but i'm just saying one
of your systems could do this and you
wouldn't need the two right okay and
that's what i wanted to clarify making
sure thank you thank you
yes representative
yeah my question is um okay so you own a
convenience store and you also own a
restaurant because your deli is
licensed as a restaurant so that's why
you need the two licenses because you
have two different businesses
it's actually a licensed combined
license as a convenience store with a
food service one food service operation
so it's a combined license okay okay all
right the key element is he doesn't have
tables right
so he is an off-premise licensee right
but i'm but i mean we'll have this
discussion later on
regarding a food truck a food truck as a
restaurant so
technically i think he is a restaurant
yeah but we don't uh the liquor
community we have a food requirement but
we don't have any restaurant
requirements just saying it's two
different licenses
so he yeah has yet another license for a
food service
if he's in a uh
one of those infamous nine cities
this year may comment on that
i think that the uh i think that
sometimes what happens is that
and into your example i think some even
the public gets a little bit uh confused
by it but we can't be confused right so
if we have a uh deli uh and there's no
seating and it's not a service it's not
a on-premise license there's no question
what happens you have to take that beer
in a bag and leave the store you can't
consume it there
so i think and again depending on what
your definition is a restaurant could be
something that you would sit down to
your point and you know have a nice
glass of wine or have a nice beer and so
again there's a gray area in that i try
to be very careful not to call it a
restaurant and i don't mean to be
disrespectful but i try very careful not
to call it that because again a lot of
public people in the public will say
well then i can sit down and why can't i
crack open the vrtr point and so i say
hey look this is a deli uh it's a
takeout deli it's take out pizza store
it's a convenience store with
off-premise license
right hope that clarifies hey well yeah
i think we got it thank you thank you
very much i have one more
card left
drew klein
is isabella in support of the bill
i'm so glad you came here you know
so
thank you i'm so glad i came too i don't
need to be uh you know long on this uh
where do i whatever the origin of this
two
cashier checkout point of sale systems
is um
and i'm not certain that it's in law i
think it may be as mr moore pointed out
an issue of the licenses tears because
as you know
each
license
requires separate record keeping and
that may be sort of the origin of it but
um
as a as a consumer
it's very frustrating you have to wait
in line and go to two different things
for the business owners i mean in our
labor shortage right now in particular
you have to staff two different fit
places and some uh brew pubs are pretty
large and so you can't buy
um you know it's a major inconvenience
for the consumer to have to
finish their meal and check out and
there are literally
six packs on the wall that you are not
allowed to buy you have to go to a
separate cash register and buy them and
in some
breweries you have to go to a separate
building uh to do that and it's just
cumbersome and
it's a regulation that
technology has um made obsolete so this
would be a good clarification for that
so i would say that i don't think this
is a
brewpub problem
okay because a brewpub license is
allowed to
sell
another
brewpub license it which
is before me right now we can blame the
room license i mean sure but it is the
total trampoline the three-tier system
because it allows you to manufacture
right stock
sell as a restaurant have mixed drinks
have cocktails outside of your own beer
products
and you can feel growlers and sell six
packs right
so yes theoretically if they if they
would just have that license
correct then they would have it but then
they have to be a restaurant and
brewpub is a as a
uh not the legal term brewpub i should
say so you're correct
stand corrected there
um all right that's all i had all right
all right thank you
i have no more cards oh you would like
to speak yes you'll fill out a card for
us yes
i registered last night oh you know i i
sort of
i'm not getting used to this yet
okay this is
1556 and somebody
signed
test the first song test
usually if the yes is supposed to pop to
the top
so you see a yes i don't see any yeses
okay
so you can fill it out afterwards don't
worry about it now
we come on come on down all right
hi sorry still getting used to the
technology also yeah we we this we had
this all down to a science before when
we didn't have in here
and and the if you signed in it me and
if you say yes to speaking it pops right
up to the top
so i don't know what happened okay go
ahead sorry about that um my name is
dennis smallner i own concord craft
brewing company which is a nanobrewery
right across the street from where you
good people park when you come here
um and i just had an audit we're nano
brewery plus which means we offer food
um and we're in under the nano brewery
license and i just had an audit on
tuesday because we are probably the
business closest to meeting the 2000
barrel limit
for um
underneath our current license and so
i've been in discussions with the liquor
commission about what we may need to do
differently when we change
and it's true
that
nano breweries and brew pubs are able to
both sell
beer to go
as well as a draft beer right across the
bar they can we can we can give a draft
beer and we can give the customer a
growler on a single transaction
up until i do 2000 barrels a year and
then i need to register as a beverage
manufacturer and get a second license
because
in order to sell
more than one pint i need a second i
need a restaurant license as well to
have an on-premise
um
license and have the ability to sell the
draft beer in addition to just producing
for you can have a food truck
uh tried that in concord
[Laughter]
maybe another city it's a little easier
um
but uh but yeah so um
so for us and i had the discussion with
my lovely auditor who was very helpful
and she did clarify to me on tuesday
that i can use the same pos system but i
think the difference is we often confuse
pos system with cash register i'm not
allowed to give that customer a growler
and a draft beer and take their credit
card under one transaction i can give
them the draft beer cash them out at the
register and then they have to walk
around to a separate location that is
not across the bar and not across a
table in order to sell beer to go
whether it's a growler or a four pack or
six this is your singular singular
license
for a beverage manufacturer currently
with a nanobrewery i can do all of that
in a single transaction with a single
pos system so she did clarify to me that
i can continue to use my pos system
because it is sophisticated enough to
calculate the difference between a draft
beer on premises and to go beer which
are taxed at different rates
but i still need to have a separate
checkout location and a separate
transaction for that customer i can't
while they're sitting there give them
beer to go which i currently do um
and in order to so we've been planning
for this um this transition and so what
we've had to do is get a second register
which obviously has a cost um get a
separate space where people can check
out that's not where they're sitting and
consuming a beer on premises
as well as have the the space in order
to do that
and i will have to tell our customers
and train our staff um that they can't
any longer provide a four pack or a
growler across the bar we need to cash
them out and then have them walk over it
hopefully we'll have this fixed before
you do that
um and i guess my only point is that it
the the nano brewery license has worked
very well for us i think we're a great
example of we're allowed to start with a
small license we invested heavily in the
brewing equipment we added food to be
able to add and the plus license to be
able to
have draft beer instead of just tasters
um covet hit and that was a little bit
difficult because we didn't have enough
capacity to distribute to supermarkets
we now do but in order to meet that
capacity and to grow our business we
have to change our license and now we
have to stop doing things the way that
have worked very well just because we
sell one more barrel or case of beer a
year than we did the last couple years
so we'll hopefully get this problem
quick fixed quickly okay
we're like i said we've invested for it
and we're prepared for it but it is an
obstacle to people like us and the
reality is it
it's not just the cost of another of
sale system is the cost of the license
each year to maintain that separate
point of sale system correct
it would certainly be easier to continue
with a single license if the beverage
manufacturer could accommodate in the
same way a nano brewery and a brute
maybe we have too many licenses maybe
that's the problem
i think you've heard this before
we're just trying to follow the laws
appreciate that it's a different
challenge for you guys okay all right
any questions
sitting down thank you for coming and
i'll fill it up let us know that we have
we are successful in our our our
philosophy when we thought the nano was
going to be a stepping stone for someone
who would then eventually become a
full-fledged custom brewer i know it's
worked really well for other groups too
so yes it has
thank you
okay
see no more uh you will fill out a card
for you i have a pillowcard okay uh so
um online we had 68 people in support
one opposed
i should i guess i could go find that
person
but um
and then on the blue sheet
it was uh no
nobody signed in on the blue sheet okay
with that i will close the public
hearing
okay
ugh
alrighty
testing one two three
yep we're on
foreign
okay we'll open up the public hearing in
house bill 1595 and hear from
the sponsor
representative wilhelm and see my card
right here oh here it is people hide it
on me so good afternoon good afternoon
you ready for me to go absolutely okay
thank you chairman hunt
uh members of the house commerce and
consumer affairs committee for the
record my name is matt wilhelm i proudly
represent hillsborough county district
42 covering manchester wards one two and
three
and that is the milliard downtown and
north end neighborhoods of manchester
colleagues i'm here today to introduce
house bill
it's an act relative to establishing a
statewide food truck license
this bill was filed
at the request of liz hitchcock a
constituent and owner of the factory on
willow which is
a living and working community of
creators innovators and entrepreneurs
has 54 studio apartments community
garden indoor and outdoor gathering and
event spaces and more
and included in that and more is the
factory's new food truck patio it is new
hampshire's first and only food truck
park with flexible all-season indoor and
outdoor space
it was through the factory's outreach to
food truck owners and operators that
they started to see how new hampshire's
patchwork style approach to food truck
licensing
is a barrier to entrepreneurship
currently there is a mobile food unit
license
which are available in a variety of
classes class d is for refrigerated
foods class f
is for packaged or frozen foods
push cart class f this is my favorite
it's limited to steamed frankfurters
or packaged food that requires
refrigeration maintained at proper
temperatures
and other mobile food units class f
for non-packaged foods that don't
require refrigeration for safety and
packaged foods that require
refrigeration maintained at specific
temperatures
in conducting research for this bill and
speaking with food truck owners and
operators
i learned about so-called
self-inspecting cities and towns
and these are municipalities that have
their own separate licensing
requirements
from the statewide mobile food unit
license
according to the department of health
and human services application for
annual
mobile food unit license
there are 15 self-inspecting
municipalities bedford berlin claremont
concord
dairy dover exeter keene
manchester merrimack nashua plaistow
portsmouth rochester and salem
and these communities in total
represent more than one-third of our
state's total population while residents
in smaller surrounding towns
uh often gravitate to these population
hubs for dining entertainment recreation
farmers markets fares and more
however in order for food trucks to
operate in these communities that i just
listed
and access the customer base in that
region of the state they must first go
through a separate and often cumbersome
licensing process
whose requirements fees and enforcement
procedures vary by municipality
the red tape that exists in new
hampshire's food truck business
landscape is overly burdensome and
unnecessarily confusing
this is especially frustrating for food
truck owners many of whom were attracted
to the business model because it allowed
them to be nimble in terms of their menu
offerings their hours
and
perhaps most importantly at least
relevant to this bill
geography that said health and safety
standards are critically important to
the food truck industry
i've been in touch with the department
of health and human services we're going
to hear from them
today
and they relayed some concerns from
self-inspecting cities and towns that
as the bill was originally drafted they
would no longer have the authority to
inspect food trucks
so i asked the office of legislative
services to draft an amendment that
strikes the word inspect
from line 16 the original bill
and
that's the that's the amendment that i
think has made its way around the room
uh and it would be my expectation that
the department of health and human
services would work through developing a
common set of standards for licensing
inspection
and enforcement through the rule making
process
in short amendment 0310h
just want to make sure that's
that's right
it's a good faith compromise it's aimed
at addressing concerns raised by
self-inspecting municipalities while
staying true
to the intent of the legislation house
bill 1595 streamlines food truck
licensing
at the state level it eliminates the
need of our for our cities and towns to
establish and enforce their own
and it frees up these entrepreneurs to
focus on what's most important earning a
living serving their neighbors and
creating jobs
i urge committee members to send house
bill 1595 to the house floor with a
strong bipartisan ought to pass
as amended recommendation and i welcome
your questions
thank you chairman
any comments yes representative bachelor
uh yes thank you sir um who will now
inspect these uh these trucks i mean if
they were being inspected i assume
by these these listed towns manchester
portsmouth etc does the state have the
uh
uh the resources to do this
uh thanks for the question
representative uh my understanding with
the fiscal note is that uh there would
be resources put against that inspection
process to make sure that
uh
all the the food trucks that are
licensed
uh have passed inspection at the state
level uh that said
you know i think after talking with some
food truck operators
you know i think they welcome
the opportunity for continued inspection
they want to make sure that they're
doing the right thing and that they're
operating in a safe way
and so
you know i think whether we're talking
about
uh health whether we're talking about
safety uh you know fire
i think you know we've got to figure out
through through the rulemaking process
what are all the standards that we're
going to
uh hold these food trucks to
and how are we going to hold them
accountable once they've been licensed
thank you
representative johnson
yes thank you for taking a big question
um
with the different
towns or cities that have these licenses
requirements now are they all
standardized betw across them are they
all different now
thank you representative for the
question
they're all a little bit different from
each other which is part of what makes
it challenging for these food truck
operators
to operate in multiple municipalities
and if there's an opportunity
for example a food truck owner an
operator who's based in manchester
uh who sees an opportunity to
participate in a community event in
nashua
because their food truck operator
friends say hey come come be part of
this they're gonna then need to go
through the process of
getting licensed in
nashua as well and there's you know
additional fees
uh and and those requirements could be a
little bit different in nashua than they
were in manchester than they were at the
statewide level and those in there we're
just talking about two municipalities
okay follow-up
yeah for the question may inquire
um
with
so say there's a city or town that
doesn't have any food truck requirements
that truck can go to that town without
any problems
is that is that what i'm understanding i
just want to make sure i understand the
whole thing the whole concept thanks for
the follow-up that is my understanding
again i put this bill i'm not a food
truck expert however i put it in at the
request of a constituent and that is my
understanding though the folks from the
department of health and human services
we'll we'll probably have a more
complete answer all right thank you very
much thank you some towns they have a
visiting uh vendor requirement that if
you're coming into town selling
something
that you're supposed to uh register with
the town
so
representative terry
uh
representative wilhelm thank you um
are you aware of any other states that
have statewide food truck licenses and
if so uh would you would you tell me
approximately how many states do and how
this bill is similar or different or
inspired by
those those those laws
thank you representative for the
question uh there are
i think
three or four other municipal or sorry
three or four other states in the
country that do have a statewide food
truck license the closest one to us is
the state of rhode island
[Music]
and i think
you know knowing that this was a request
from a constituent who's who's sort of
understanding the lay of the land of
food truck industry
i wouldn't be surprised if this you know
came across her desk and she said oh
this is something that maybe could work
in the state of new hampshire
representative
thank you representative wilhelm did you
speak to um someone from the health
department in the city uh regarding this
bill
i did not well i i did at length and
they
don't feel that this bill is workable
but i did suggest that on their website
in the state website they could have a
portal which can direct food truck
owners
just giving them you know direction on
how to operate in certain you know towns
and cities so it really is a local rule
local control issue
uh but i'm sure we'll hear from the you
know the state health department but you
know my daughter has a food truck so
i've been doing some research for her as
well
but i do i do agree it is very
cumbersome
not only for food trucks for but for you
know
individuals that own restaurants that
want to participate in a fair in
manchester that's a whole other but very
similar a lot of you know rules and
regulations and fees and so um thank you
for bringing the bill forward
any other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you
uh let's see
um
olivia
uh oh knox bruh huh
yeah okay
good afternoon
hi everyone thanks for having me today
my name is olivia lennox i was born and
raised in manchester new hampshire i
opened my first food truck in portland
oregon in the year of 2018.
i sold that food truck in 2020 moved
back to manchester and i now operate a
food truck in manchester and we've been
operating since september of last year
i don't have anything prepared but
um i came here because i am in support
of
the bill in front of you
um
i'm parked at the factory on willow
which is actually a brand new food truck
pod there are four spots for food trucks
um i was the first one
to be parked there there's a second
truck now and
they're recruiting more more food trucks
to come and join um so
i think that you know they're sending
people my way and um wanting me to
explain the process
and i'm having a hard time you know
helping them out because there is so
many steps
and as of right now i didn't get the new
hampshire state
license because i'm not operating
outside of manchester
but if i wanted to operate in any of the
smaller towns not the 15 municipalities
but any of the smaller towns i actually
wouldn't be able to do that either i'm
basically only allowed to operate in
manchester right now
which is fine i could actually i know
that i could go
[Music]
through this state and get a 225 dollar
license there's some there's a process
with
you know them coming out and inspecting
the state statewide coming out to
inspect and
me sending in a floor plan and then i
would have the ability to move
throughout the state but not in any of
the 15 municipalities only in smaller
towns and then manchester where i'm
currently licensed
and then if i wanted to go to any of the
larger cities which is where the money
is for me you know um i'd have to go
through their individual city clerk's
offices so
i do think that this bill would
streamline that process for a lot of
food truck owners and um i do know one
other food truck right now who
they didn't they weren't aware of how
long this process could possibly take
for the licensing so they built their
food truck out they put their money into
their dream
and it's just kind of sitting there and
they're waiting for the bureaucratic
process to to carry out which can take
time and can be confusing and it
involves a lot of different stops along
the way a lot of different checks that
you're writing out to a lot of different
people and i think that streamlining
that process would just make food trucks
a lot more accessible to the people of
new hampshire
and i welcome any questions
representative emmon
thank you for coming to our committee
and uh
i appreciate this bill the spirit of
this bill and this is what you believe
would you believe i had a friend a few
years ago that wanted to start a food
truck
in the town of goffstown and spent
upwards of ten thousand dollars getting
it ready and had to abandon the project
because she couldn't find uh she
couldn't find a location so
would you believe that
so
representative herbert
my microphone
from manchester i'm i'm always a little
uh
closer i'm always a little defensive
when i think that somebody
is not going to pay the city for what it
does
and
but the other part is
these other steps you mentioned
what are they
thank you for your question and um so
the steps are
i went to the city clerk first and i got
a peddler's and hawker's license
application
that had a lot of different
things that needed to be included so i
did come here to the secretary of state
and i got a state peddlers and honkers
license which is something manchester
city clerk required i'm not sure who
else requires that but i drove here and
got that
it involved obviously the inspections of
the food truck which were fire
um
there was also the parks and rec sign
off and the whole health inspection with
the floor plan and all that stuff so
that was kind of separate but it was
attached to this peddlers and hawkers
application
and there was also a five-year
background check in any of the states
i'd lived in in the past five years so
actually i was late opening my food
truck by a week because i was waiting
for the state of oregon
to send me a background check for the
past five years to make sure that i
wasn't like a criminal even though i did
i did get a clear background check from
new hampshire so there's just i think
that that packet the peddlers and
honkers might look different in the
different municipalities but in
manchester there was a lot of different
steps and a lot of different things that
needed to be attached
follow-on question
for the question main choir so um
the city of manchester had this
peddler's license
and they did some inspection work
or
just that's just for the license
and then you went to concord
and they charged you for
the same license
yes i did pay for the peddlers and
honkers license which is a state
peddlers and hawker's license i also
paid for a background check
i'm just trying to get work through the
checklist here the um
so that's
two peddlers and licenses
uh
which i don't know why there are two if
you're if you're going to be
working in manchester
but
you mentioned a five-year residency
requirement
it was a five-year background check in
any of the places that i was a resident
so
because i was a new hampshire resident
within the past five years i needed a
background check and because i was a
resident of oregon within the past five
years i needed an oregon background
check if i had lived anywhere else in
the past five years i would have needed
a background check from that state
um
so
i understand the background check that
makes sense to me i i don't know about
oregon but
that's like did i have any priors but
the background check says where have you
been in the last five years yeah
and it could only be one year in oregon
but it could have been the fifth year
all right so like
i can see things that could be done a
little more smoothly but i still don't
i still can't get away from the fact
that
the cities are bringing to these
business people
populations places that you know that
they can work
and there's a lot of support
for them compared to a smaller town so i
would be i would if you could clean it
up
and make it not so obtrusive
then i would
i would look a lot more kindly on it but
yeah would you believe would you believe
uh yes okay we got it good good question
representative burroughs
thank you mr chair and i have a question
um hopefully you can answer somebody
else um because i'm trying to understand
the process let's say you're coming up
to my community in north conway and you
have a state you'll have a state line
what the statewide license what else
would you need to do if you either
wanted to park on a street or go to an
event
so yes i would need the statewide
license to go to your community assuming
it wasn't in one of the 13
municipalities
i i'm as far as health and fire when it
um in your in your community i'm not
sure i'm assuming i would need to
approach
health and fire or approach your your
um
town hall and see if there's any kind of
slip that does say like a daily event
slip i know that they do that for
a lot of pop-up events not necessarily
for food trucks but for vendors like a
farmer's market for example
i'd assume the process was was similar
there if it wasn't in one of the 13
municipalities
so follow up so you so you'd have to
check with the individual town to see
what else you needed to do right because
the i it is my understanding that the
the state license at this moment it may
have to it is the department of health
and human services so i know that they
do require a floor plan and they come
and do an inspection so it's possible
that if i had that maybe it was a 365
day long application through the state
the health department of health and
human services that i'd be able to go to
your community without any
additional health or fire inspections
and i could just show up if that makes
sense if i have the state the state
license right now thank you
representative him
thank you
um
if you get the state license
does the state license cover you for
on public property private parties um
private property all kinds would it
cover everywhere you happen to
be
or are the different licenses you need
for private property versus
public
thank you um i believe that that was
where parks and rec came in when it came
to manchester um but if it's a private
event i think that i can be there if i'm
licensed through the state assuming it's
not in one of the 15 municipalities i
think i can be
private and
i will i do want to mention that
through the health department and the
city clerk in manchester they did want
to know they wanted a copy of my lease
so it is important if it's public
property or private property assuming
it's not a private event i believe i
mean i did need to provide a copy of my
lease with the factory on willow so that
they knew where and when i was going to
be there and that i had permission to be
there
and i do have one other thing to say i
just think in a perfect world i would be
able to go through the state and get a
new hampshire food truck license
i'd be able to go to any of the 15
municipalities as well as any of the
other towns in new hampshire however i
do think and welcome that the larger
cities the municipalities
do continue to do the fire and health
inspections on top of the state
inspections i think that's what's most
important but it would allow food truck
operators to do what
what they're meant to do you know when
you think food truck you think you
travel around and you sell your food to
different communities and i think that
right now that's just not very possible
representative billio
thank you for taking my question
did the um did the property owner where
the food truck pad is did they
give you any type of information
regarding
licensing for food trucks because you
are leasing
space there and did they give you
a packet of information just say okay
this is before you sign the lease
this is what you need to do in
manchester did they do that for you
thank you for your question they did not
um i think because that was more of a
business transaction they assumed that i
as a food i mean it was just a lease and
um they don't know
they don't know you know they're it's a
apartment building they don't know the
rules so they
they asked me to sign the lease and they
did go over like for example they do not
provide waste water
removal so i found that on my own and
they did require that i
in state where i was going to be
disposing of my waste water they did
outline what was available to me through
my lease which was you know 50 amps to
plug into regularly as well as fresh
water
but they didn't give me any insight onto
how to get licensed because it's really
just not their job i think they'd like
to if they were more informed or if if
they knew more
yes
i think it is their job because it is
their property but i also wanted to know
do you have a commissary there
um i have a commissary kitchen it is not
at that property because i own a meal
prep company so i will say that in
general the process of licensing my food
truck was a little bit easier for me in
that way because i am licensed with the
commissary but not because of my food
truck because of my other business
which is one llc so i already had a
commissary kitchen
thank you
representative bartlett
thanks mr chair this is very um helpful
to us because i don't think a lot of us
know a whole lot about this
um could you give me an idea of what the
costs are for these various licenses
and for the background check what do you
what are your startup costs
yes thank you um so i the one that i
don't have which is this new hampshire
state
license is 225 dollars for a mobile food
unit i i decided not to get that one
because i decided not to leave
manchester
um at the city clerk i believe that my
peddlers and hawker's license and this
was
for myself two licenses was 100 150
but if i were to get more so
for example with the peddlers and
hawkers license you aren't allowed to
exchange money without it
so
when i hire a new individual to work for
me i'll need to get them a badge as well
so i'm not sure if that fits into my
current license but that was 150
the health inspection
without the commissary because i had
already dealt with that i believe was
around 300
all-encompassing
including the commissary for my original
space i did just renew and it was 325
dollars
um
so and then i think i wrote a check to
um the background check for like 25
and i think the secretary of state was
about 50
somewhere between 25 and 50. parks and
rec didn't charge me they just signed
off because i was going to be legally on
a private property where i had a lease
and not in any kind of park
so i believe that was everything
thank you
thank you very much
colleen smith come on up
so
is there a state law now for food trucks
yeah the button there you go
got it all right good afternoon members
of the committee my name is colleen
smith i'm the administrator for the food
protection section within dhhs
and i'm happy to answer any questions
around 1595.
as it stands now there is it's not a
statewide food truck license we license
all the
217 cities and towns in new hampshire
outside of the self-inspecting so a food
a food truck or a mobile food unit as we
define them can move about in the areas
that we
are under our jurisdiction but as was
mentioned in previous testimony if they
want to operate in one of those
self-inspecting jurisdictions such as
manchester concord they'd have to obtain
a permit from that city
and as it was mentioned is it's not
not necessarily limited to just a
permit from the health department but it
could involve other requirements as such
as a hawkers and peddler's license
um as as also as mentioned as we if if
this bill were to pass we do anticipate
we need additional resources to take on
the additional work um as as was
mentioned before
if somebody was
operating exclusively in manchester they
wouldn't require our license for a
health permit but
they would be inspected by that city
health department
one of the other areas that the bill
doesn't speak to is how to handle
temporary events because
exempt from a state license is anyone
operating in conjunction with a
temporary event such as a fairer
festival that's not longer than 14 days
in duration so this would be your fair
like your deerfield fares your hopkinton
fares those mobile food units that are
operating exclusively there we don't
license because they're exempt from a
state food license however many of the
cities and towns they that are
self-inspecting they do issue temporary
food licenses for those types of events
and so
that's not if the state food truck
license were to pass that isn't
addressed specifically if those cities
and towns would still be able to do
that temporary food permit
even if they had a statewide food
license
um and i i know there are probably many
questions about the the current
regulation so i'm happy to answer those
okay so help me out here so what is
are we creating a new truck license
so so as i understand the bill is if
there was a new food truck license that
the cities and towns that are
self-inspecting
they they wouldn't be able to issue
their own that the state their licenses
would supersede that's kind of that
preemption which brings up a whole can
of worms but i'm just trying to get down
to
where what is the statute for
the
because i keep seeing new new statute
and and i look in here and it is a new
statute
so
do we have a statewide food truck
license now
so
a food truck is defined as a food as a
type of food establishment and so right
now it fits into requiring a food
license because it's offering food to
the public and where we have
jurisdiction at the state health
department is those
all all but the 15 self-inspecting
cities and towns though
any food establishment currently in one
of those that falls to the local
municipality for
food licensing and inspection
so it's that this license when you say
state license statewide license not
withstanding the communities have their
own
it it's also for restaurants it's the
same license for restaurants same it's
everybody it's not it's not anything to
do about having wheels and moving
correct it is a type of license so a
restaurant is one type of license yeah
so what what is the one that that people
would be falling under now
so it's it's under our regular food
license food licensing
143 a4
license required yes
okay so that doesn't get you anything
about traveling or moving or anything
just that's just the license to
to have and gets you guys on record so
you know that there's somebody
selling food out of that location right
so so in essence the issue the license
that's issued by the state isn't
isn't statewide in that you can operate
in the self-inspecting cities and towns
without their license similar to a
restaurant if a restaurant was in
manchester or concord they'd have to go
to the local the health department so
for most of our little towns
the people who have these trucks and
campers
um
they get this license to with you
and then most of towns they just have a
code enforcement or whatever whatever
and comes in and looks at it and and and
treats it like any other restaurant
yes okay it had nothing to do whether it
might be in that town that day versus
going to another town another day it
would be based upon that day okay now i
get it representative
thank you i'm going to ask the same
question of you as i did of the sponsor
uh from your perspective uh at the state
uh department that regulates here are
are you aware of any other states that
have
the type of uh have laws that are
similar to the one that's proposed in
this legislation
um and if
uh that's part a to the question
uh
and
could you compare and contrast with with
respect
to this proposed legislation
um and and then part b are you aware of
any other states
that effectively bifurcate between towns
and cities
uh in the issuing of uh food truck
licenses thank you
so i don't know the the exact number um
as representative wilhelm mentioned
before that seems reas reasonable there
are there are a few states that are
centralized rhode island being one of
them where they handle all food
licensing they don't handle they don't
handle and they don't have
municipalities that individually license
our neighbor to the south massachusetts
every single town
has their own licensing authority they
so there is no state
food inspection program for restaurants
each individual city in town does the
food licensing so it's it's really
patchwork across the country new
hampshire is is kind of a hybrid where
much most of the state is handled by the
state health department but we do have
those 15 self-inspecting municipalities
okay representative bartlett
thank you mr chair
welcome back to commerce um
do you have any idea of how many of
these licenses
are i i'm guessing that there's a
turnover
each year because you don't see
old
it long in business food trucks
but you have an idea of how many
licenses you might issue in a year for
food trucks we have we have well over
200 and i don't have information i could
i can try to find for you how many
how it would be a little bit hard for us
to find out how many are turning over on
a year-to-year basis um definitely we
have seen growth in this class and
category of license over the last
10 years they're definitely becoming
more popular than than they were
and maybe even related to the the
pandemic it also could could have
caused the increase in the number of
them
for the question main choir thank you um
and and do you have to do an on-site
inspection of each of these trucks each
year
so we
don't necessarily inspect them annually
they
it would probably be from one to two
years of an inspection depend it's where
you do them risk-based so depending on
their menu that's that's how they how
frequently they'd be inspected
let me ask one more question further
question thank you um
and then
so if you're
so let's say every two years they get
inspected
um
i mean i'm thinking about the costs and
what the licensing does and how long has
it been since the license fee has been
changed
so for this cloud class and category
actually for all our food licensing we
haven't increased our fees since 2009.
okay thank you
representative mack later uh thank you
chairman hunt um i think what you said
was that if a state law passes that
would preclude the the city laws is
there any reason you can't do both in
other words we have a state law but if
the city decides to
uh to handle this licensing themselves
that they could opt to do it i think
that was somewhat what the
representative terry was a direction he
was going so we could have both
why not
or could we have both
so so that might um
but it's right now they could they could
have
an operator could have both they could
have a license to operate within the
state i think the tricky part is how to
navigate the the self-inspecting
municipalities with them
you know some you know for instance if
someone wanted to operate in in hooksett
nashua concord and manchester that could
be for food licenses for for them as it
is now
right so
really
we wouldn't want double jeopardy here
either
having two licenses like who's really in
charge
so it really the statute should say is
if
if you have uh if you want uh do a town
that's not
currently
one of the 15 or 13 towns
then you could get a state license okay
you might still have two if you go back
and forth between one town and a city
but at the end of the day
that the
the towns
excuse me the city
has jurisdiction over that city so that
we should be writing this state statute
and i would say would you agree whether
you write the state statute we should
say this is only if you're not in a town
that has its own license
that this license should only be good if
you know even though manchester requires
you to go get one
but that but that we have to decide who
at the end of the day who's uh who's
your authority in a given place
so if you're if you're in a city it's
going to be that city if you're in the
town it can be it would be the state
right right i think that that's how it
is working right now is that all right
but this bill doesn't say this this bill
it appears to say
if you have the state win then you don't
need to have the local one and that can
be
that can be a that a problem
yes okay um so uh the the fiscal note
says
225 dollars for 175 licenses which was
the 175. so we had surveyed the the
number of mobile food units that are in
the self-inspecting jurisdiction so if
we were to license all 100 approximately
175 of those that that's where that
figure came into so in addition to the
200 plus that are in the state currently
there are about 175 food trucks within
the self-inspecting communities okay so
i guess what i what i want to know is uh
are we is the money coming from peter to
pay paul because this dollar amount does
not make enough for the person who's
going to need to be hired
right right that's um
that's
that's one of the
difficulties is that we would definitely
need an additional staff person to take
on this additional right and the two and
if we were to do that we probably need
to raise the fee because it won't pay
for the pay for the position if there's
only 175 people signing up
okay
any question representative bros
this is a would you believe um
would you believe in my community a
group of high school students started a
food truck cheese louise
and it has grown into a significant
business they now have two restaurants
in two different states and they hire a
significant number of people so i so i i
think it behooves us to try to make this
process as simple and as cost effective
as possible because these these folks
are now employing a sizable group of
people
and they have an excellent product thank
you
would you believe
okay everybody else had oh
representative bowling yeah
thank you for taking my question
if you if you're a food truck um in the
state do you need a
peddler's license and
a license to operate
the food truck as a restaurant because a
food truck is a restaurant
so
a peddler's license applies to food
vendors and in any vendor as it was
mentioned before that exchange of money
i don't i can't answer the question
about each individual municipality that
requirement but i do know
there is that state hackers and peddlers
requirement for any mobile vendor okay
representative johnson
thanks for taking my question so just so
i can understand it so not only when a
person wants to open a food truck
business that's not doesn't fall into
one of these jurisdictions
they would need to come in and get a
food truck license
as a restaurant or a restaurant and a
peddler's license so they have to pay
for two
fees and then if they want to go into
one of these businesses they could
potentially have to pay for two more
fees at this at the local levels to be
able to operate in those communities
also so you're looking at four
so so for a mo any mobile vendor or
mobile
whether it mobile food whether it's
they're selling t-shirts they're
required to get that hawkers and
peddlers license if they're selling food
they all in the state's jurisdiction
then they have to receive a food license
from us if they want to operate in a in
the states jurisdiction and the city
then they also need to meet the city
requirements which may involve a health
permit and a hawkers and peddler's
license right the answer so the question
is if you're doing two different doing a
city and a town
yes there's you would have to get four
licenses yeah that's i just want to make
sure i understood it you don't want to
move it around too much
okay representative bartlett
thank you mr chair so um basically from
these numbers that we're looking at
um it would seem to me that we're
i mean pretty much the license is the
service for the inspections
because it's not a program that pays for
itself
even so
so
so over overall our program is is pretty
it's pretty much revenue neutral and in
the amount of licensing revenue that we
generate and then the the cost to run
our program and so that but just this
this additional work is would be a it
would be above and beyond and then it's
also
more expanding the geography also
knowing that we don't normally go in to
do inspections in in these
municipalities right so it's either
we have to come up with more money for
the state inspections
or the vendors that need the inspection
need to pay for it
if it was to be uh cost neutral yes okay
thank you
okay thank you very much
uh chair we'll call on drew klein
uh hi mr chairman committee thank you
again this will be my last time
appearing today
um so the science bartlett center for
public policy is the free market
organization new hampshire
uh we are here to testify on this bill
we've done some research on on food
truck regulations in new hampshire and
iron i read of this bill
is this
creates a
truly for the first time statewide food
truck license
as you've heard and just to
maybe explain a little better the
current system requires food truck
vendors
to get a state permit
but then also if they want to serve in
any of the 15 municipalities that that
are self-regulated they have to purchase
annually a separate
vendor permit in each of those
communities so when we a couple years
ago did a big report on food trucks in
new hampshire which are very popular
among the younger crowd and if you're
talking about stay work play trying to
attract young people food trucks are a
quality of life issue
for folks in their 20s 30s and 40s
before the pandemic
there was a 70 percent increase in food
truck application the the license
applications at the state level for food
truck vendors in the three and a half
years before the pandemic started
and yet what municipalities saw was
there wasn't a significant increase in
actual food trucks on the road
and that's because of the municipal
license problems
people would not be able to go from one
municipality to another to another so i
interviewed a food truck vendor
who spent more than fifteen hundred
dollars a year
getting permits in a region around
southern new hampshire and northern
massachusetts
so just to give you an example now this
is
these
permits might have gone up but when i
did the story
212 in concord 250 in another town 200
in another town 150 in another town
you're quickly adding up so what this
would do is allow the state
health department
to
license and inspect the food trucks so
they would be inspected
and then you could truly drive them
around and the local municipality
could still have food truck regulations
they can regulate location
for the most part
which nobody's taking that away from
them and in the bottom of the bill you
see the last line of the bill my
computer screen went black uh billing
but you can read it um
it allows them to have a few other
regulatory so you're not taking
everything away from the municipalities
but what you are doing is
consolidating it into a statewide
license so that people can truly
offer these popular
food trucks all around the state so we
think it would be
a good bill it would
increase competition and allow people to
provide a service at lower cost that is
really in high demand in new hampshire
right now and we hear
um you know if you talk to to folks in
manchester at their office their
licensing office and portsmouth
they get queries all the time from
local residents and why why aren't there
more food trucks where are the food
trucks um people really want them but
the problem is the those local licensing
uh problems and
they are different so you would have to
it's not just the fee
you would have to pass a different
license requirement in portsmouth than
you would in manchester that you
wouldn't conquer then you would in keene
and it's very difficult and discouraging
and so this statewide license would
really free these food trucks to operate
statewide we think it would be a great
great thing for new hampshire
happy to take any questions yep are you
saying
if you're in one of these cities
and they have the capability of
inspecting them you still have to get
their license right are you thinking the
state license is all they need to get
as i read the bill um currently and you
heard the sponsor say inspection is in
the bill for at the state level they
there's an amendment that the sponsor
mentioned before that would take
inspection out that would i assume if
that amendment passes it would allow the
locals to still inspect
i i think not having read the amendment
but i think that's potentially a problem
again you
ideally you want one inspection
at the state level you don't want the
food truck to have to get inspected in
three or four or five different
municipalities um because again you're
you're raising the burden so ideally
you'd have it just in one place and to
answer terry's question
starting in 2016
utah became the first state
to my knowledge to to do a statewide
food truck license that was followed by
arizona
i'm in 2017 or 18 and then in 2018 rhode
island did one
and
for all the same reasons if you go back
and read those stories they had food
trucks that had just massive problems
getting licensed in all the different
municipalities and
um i mean the sponsor for the rhode
island bill has become pretty popular in
newport because
he freed the food trucks in newport so
um washington state also has a statewide
licensing for food trucks but i'm not
sure i don't know the details of that
bill and how similar it is to this one
so there aren't many states but
it has been something that's been coming
up in the last few years because of the
popularity of food trucks
representative bartlett
thank you mr chair
so with this amendment
um correct me if i'm wrong the amendment
would
not allow
the municipality whatever the wherever
the
municipality is located
to be able to inspect
say there's a problem on a food truck i
i haven't read the amendment as i
read the bill the bill as written would
take the state the inspections at the
state level and that
and i think i think what the amendment
would do is allow municipalities to also
inspect but then they wouldn't get
compensated i don't know
i can't answer that i don't know the
answer to that thank you um
representative billio
yes uh thank you mr chair thank you for
taking the question um
in in doing a lot of research on food
trucks have you talked to town planners
planning departments yep
and um i i
is there a problem
do you think that
would you believe that i
town planners or the planning department
have
they are responsible for allowing these
food trucks to be in a certain area so
would you believe that i think we should
be
working with the town planners or the
city planners to
adjust
this food truck um
you know sure i'm happy to address that
so the bill as written would not
interfere in any way in the town's
ability to regulate the locations of
food trucks so that that means
they can still tell through the zoning
planning ordinances they can regulate
where
and when and how many food trucks are in
town all that stuff remains a local
um priority and this bill doesn't change
that so
so would you believe that that is a big
hurdle oh no it is one of the big
reasons why there aren't food trucks in
manchester oh no that's that's exactly
right i wasn't going to get into that
issue because that's not really part of
the spill but
it's a whole food it's a different issue
but um zoning regulations of where food
trucks so in manchester particular and
portsmouth the zoning are are two of the
major reasons why you don't have more
food trucks but that's not
directly related to this bill
so make sure you get this right so
the intent of this legislation is that
there would be one-stop shopping for a
license yes and that the cities and
towns can still
require a license but
they're not going to be allowed to
charge for one
as
i read it and i can if you bear with me
here the amendment looks the amendment
looks like to me that that it says not
required it's kind of confusing because
it says
to to offer a license
uh
it says abyssal shall not require a
separate license or permit to operate a
food truck whether they miss valley
unless you already have a license so if
you don't have a separate the town can't
issue a license
but you're saying it's okay they can
expect
but
uh john hunt's rule of licensure is the
reason we have licensure is so we can
take it away from you right so no town
is going to be happy
if we say well you you can go in
and inspect but you don't ha you don't
have any control over the license the
state does correct that's how so i just
got this for the first time right just
reading it now so i'm a little worried
that this amendment is problematic but
let's understand let's just agree with
what we want to agree on so we're hoping
is is the state could have be able to
issue a license
one-stop shopping right
and uh and and i guess
if if it gets down to that this only can
be
everywhere except in these towns that
have decided to have their own license
right so that's the way it works now
right is you you can't go into those
towns without getting their license so
ideally what you would have is a
situation where you get a food truck
license from the state
and then your only
um
legal process with the local town is to
register
and not to apply for a new license and
inspection and that i think is what this
bill tries to do is make sure that you
you can register with the municipalities
so you're on their books they know who
you are they have your license plate
number all that sort of stuff but
they're not inspected just took their
revenue away yes
for them to be able to go out and do
that inspection well right and then the
original bill they're not allowed to
inspect in the original bill
it's it the inspection happens well the
original was put
their inspection was not necessary
because right the licensure body is the
state right which i think would
just from my own personal point of view
that would be preferable as a one-stop
shop i say this one's the best
but ideally however you work out the
details i think the point is you want
that
thank you so i just want to be uh clear
in summarizing what i believe that i've
been hearing today
that um the intent of the bill
is to eliminate redundancy
such that
in today's
environment
if a food truck wanted to operate in all
15 cities as well as the state right
that that that that would involve 16
different inspections correct at the
cost of hundreds upon hundreds of
dollars correct yes yes
so if we want to make if we want to make
it easier for entrepreneurs
right to operate food trucks
offer that service in the state
and we want to make it easier for
consumers
who would like to patronize a food truck
in manchester that they patronized in
[Music]
dixville notch
they'd have an easier time to do that
because the cost on the provider of
operating in that truck would be
significantly reduced because we'd be
eliminating the redundancies of the same
types and they might not even be the
exact same
inspections because the currently the
rules in the cities as to what
constitutes an inspection would are
different
than the statewide and differ from city
to city correct which would absolutely
be
a disincentive to somebody to be able to
operate throughout the entire state
in addition to the fact that they would
be driven out of their mind as well as
bankrupted thank you right and i think
again the point is
so i think you have to think of what's
the point of inspection
i mean that's that's the real question
right it's it's public health and safety
right so if the state is
taking over that portion of the
licensing inspection the state is saying
department of health and human services
we are inspecting these and we are
issuing them a license and we're
verifying that they meet all the
requirements for public health and
safety
then what's the point of getting an
additional local inspection
that you don't want to
i don't know why you would add the local
inspection on top of it if the state is
doing the inspection and saying yes i
mean i understand why municipalities
are reluctant to give up you know
inspection authority but again if the
goal is simply to ensure for the public
that if you see a food truck and has a
new hampshire license and a permit on
there it has been state inspected for
health and safety you don't need the
redundancy of local inspections on top
of that
okay represent immaculate real quickly
um
if the state is doing the issuing of the
license does that preclude a
municipality of charging a vendor's
license wouldn't they still have that
opportunity i think they would as i read
the bill
the last line of the bill is that
nothing shall prevent the municipality
from enforcing local land use regulation
zoning and other ordinances in relation
to the operation of a food truck within
its borders so i think you could have
some sort of
obviously you'd have to register that
town and you could probably have some
sort of vendor registration that kind of
thing
okay all right thank you thank you
uh
russ conley
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for holding this hearing today
just for the record my name is ross
connolly i'm the deputy state director
for americans for prosperity here in new
hampshire uh here to voice our support
for hb5 uh 1595. uh
i think that we've been discussing this
quite a bit it can be a complicated
issue but the crux of the matter is that
the the current process is incredibly
cumbersome and difficult for
anyone who wants to open and operate a
food truck in the state of new hampshire
as representative terry pointed out you
would need 16 different licenses
16 different sets of rules across the
state if you if
you you'd like to operate a truck across
the state of new hampshire uh those 15
municipalities that do self-inspection
uh they they happen to be the the
largest uh municipalities in the state
that's where food trucks would want to
operate as the the previous speaker from
the department of health and human
services mentioned
uh there's 200 total to around 200 total
food trucks operating in the state 174
of those are in those self-inspecting
towns so the real issue is the conflict
between those 15 towns and the
differences between those and for an
individual business owner just trying to
make a buck and grow their business they
have to navigate through
15 16 different sets of rules that it's
very confusing it's it's hard for them
to do and some towns are more onerous
than others i live in the town of
merrimack
there's a business in town called abel
ebenezer uh they're a brewery that does
not do food so they have food trucks
come to their their location and
unfortunately it's difficult to get food
trucks into the town of merrimack
because the process is very cumbersome
um
so for these reasons we think the the
original intent of the bill i i do have
the amendment i i can't uh i haven't
looked at it that closely so i can't
comment on that but what we'd really
like to see is just a more streamlined
process for these business owners to
operate in new hampshire and and we
think the original bill uh definitely
accomplishes that so i'd be happy to
take any questions
representing billio uh yes thank you mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um could you talk a little bit about
local control
oh thank you for the question
representative regards to this bill i i
think local control in some areas is a
good idea this is not one of those areas
in in my opinion uh
just because again it's so confusing
for people to go from town to town and
and and try to understand the
differences of the rules i think a more
streamlined state wide process obviously
as as uh the previous speaker mentioned
uh
the town would still have a great say
over where these these trucks are
operating uh they would have a say over
over things like local registrations
hawkers and peddlers uh local licenses
things like that it's just
in terms of the rules for operating a
food truck in particular there should be
a single rule at the state level so that
uh these business owners can operate
more easily
and just a follow-up about
municipalities if all of these cities um
municipalities do not agree with this
bill do not like this bill and they're
you know it's all about local control i
mean how
how how can you get past that
uh thank you for the question
representative i i again i i just go
back to
what what we'd like to see is to make
this a simpler process for the business
owners that's our biggest concern is is
there are people that are operating in
the state now that are struggling to do
it and contribute to communities these
food trucks
operate across the country uh
in in are extremely popular for younger
generations if you go to any city across
the country
most of them have a a line of food
trucks uh in business centers and and
live work play areas
uh we i'd like to see that the same for
the state of new hampshire and and we
believe that this bill would make that
that easier and bring that commerce to
those localities
representative terry
yeah with respect to the uh
the uh
the concern or the issue raised about
local control
i want to be careful about how i
phrased this uh
do you do you do you see any difference
between
appropriate health standards for food
trucks in alton compared to manchester
thank you for the question
representative uh
no that
again
the food standard should be applied
equally across the state of new
hampshire
you know that aspect of of uh you know
local differences and regulations makes
it very very confusing and and uh we
streamlining that making that more clear
uh i think helps the business owners to
actually grow their business
if there's different role from alton to
meredith to moultonborough
uh
you know that's just around lake
winnipesaukee that would be extremely
confusing
if you're moving around
lake winnipesaukee let alone the 15
largest
municipalities in the state that do have
different rules
representative herbert
microphone
[Music]
just a couple observations
about one
if you if uh would you believe
that the cities those 15 cities
might have an interest in exactly where
those locations can be
so in other words if there is a
restriction
you're not against restricting zoning
laws or anything like that so that
you the cities have the up i still have
the option of
determining where the food trucks can be
thank you for the question
representative yes
as i read the original bill the cities
towns would still have that control that
that's appropriate uh
otherwise you could have them you know
in residential neighborhoods or
something obviously people wouldn't
wouldn't care for that uh so they would
the planning boards in in local towns or
cities would still have that that
oversight over where they can operate uh
and as has been mentioned registering
them so we we know who is operating in
each locality uh just in terms of the
most cumbersome onerous uh levels of
regulation that that should be a a more
streamlined process but as it turns it
comes to you know operating within it
within a locality uh the those those
municipalities will will still have the
ability to to tell them where they can
operate where they cannot question of
the chair have we determined whether or
not the municipalities the 15
municipalities will still have the legal
right to charge
a fee for
being doing business in our towns
at this point the intent of the bill is
no
the intent of the bill is that you have
one registration with the state
now
it does beg the question if then you go
to a town and they also say well okay so
we're not going to get you for that
license but you still got to do the
hawkers and peddler's license
so you really so the problem really is
how much have you really solved
if every town you go to you still have
to get the hacker and peddler's license
anyways
let alone the fact that you have the
state license
i guess the savings is that you
won't have to get
two licenses
when you go to manchester or go to these
cities or three you only have to get one
so that's what you streamline but um
i don't know i i i would encourage uh
the members to maybe reach out to the
secretary of state's office they handle
the statewide hawkers and peddler's
license i personally don't know if the
local license is no it does that bill
came through this committee and i
remember this issue
intimately
yeah i guess my right this is a bill
that looks like it sounds great on paper
but boy it's it's going to be problem
imply you know doing implementing it
mainly because
i think the zoning you talk about the
zoning location in my experience
yes in college towns the college
literally
the town has figured out a street that
they want them all lined up and they're
all
you know like you say this
there's a parking lot you know parking
for them and that
and uh because the zoning of them is
limited and because they also need
electricity and water a lot of times and
so there and that that's goes back to
the landlord and how many leases that
you have so the idea that anyone is
going to want to get a license in all 16
towns
i just don't i just can't imagine that
ever happening because that you would
spend more time going around negotiating
leases and doing all that stuff
so i i understand the intent is to try
to streamline this and how do we make it
simpler and easier
and and that's the charge for this
committee to figure that out
represented him yes thank you
um would you believe um
i have some concerns about the local
control issue
the perception of the town
that
this particular industry
or economic opportunity or whatever
is being
controlled or dictated by the state
leaving the municipality with
maybe just the hours of operation or
parking or a few other details
i think it sounds like a good idea but
would you believe
i would be sensitive
to the impression
that we're giving to the towns that
were taking over
uh regulating this industry
and perhaps getting a little pushback
would you believe
i i
understand that concern representative
uh but the state does many things from
it from a state level in terms of
registration and licensing and and we
view this as an appropriate change
to again you're still working with the
localities on location
possibly on on the hawkers and peddler's
license they still have a large say over
over what's happening i view this as a
collaboration between local and state
government
and this this would uh
you know just just something that would
really really help these small business
owners to help grow their business
great thank you very much thank you uh
having no more cards
uh
nothing on the blue sheet here and the
sign in the overnight sign in we had
nine people in support and three opposed
and with that i will close the public
hearing and yes this will go to a
subcommittee
now i know why we never had this
the public hearing on
1095 and hear from the prime spencer
representative wolf good afternoon
representative wolf i'm sorry you were
delayed but i'm sure you wanted to hear
all about the regulatory authority over
these wonderful delivery of food to our
community
thank you uh mr chairman members of the
house commerce
and consumer affairs committee i hope i
won't take as long on this relatively
simple bill of a hot dog
with sauerkraut or chile
but
i come before you today in support of hb
1095 a very simple piece of legislation
for those 15 cities and towns and you've
heard a lot about them that do not have
their own
health inspector that regulates
restaurant there is no ability to have a
push cart that provides fresh condiments
other than in these 15 cities and towns
you cannot get
sauerkraut or chili or fresh veggies on
a hot dog
the state of new hampshire does not have
rules or regulations that provide for
that ability
the only mechanism as i understand it is
for each vendor to get a specific
variance from the department of health
and human services
the state health department inspects the
push carts at least once once a year so
we're not asking for a change in
inspection or anything like that
in my discussions with the department
the process that they cited seemed to me
to be overly difficult
to obtain a variance items such as
preparation in a certified kitchen
and i can go on appear overly regulated
for example if the vendor buys pre-made
chili
brings it home
and takes the intended daily supply to a
push card keeping it at a serve safe
temperature the whole time
why is running water a three-based sink
or a certified commercial kitchen
necessary
what i am asking for in this bill
is the department of health and human
establish rules and regulations and that
such rules be reasonable
a simple push cut vendor should not be
limited in making a living and providing
the public with a desired
product such as condiments on a hot dog
i'll be happy to answer any questions
but it's a relatively simple bill you've
heard about the other 15 towns
and we have a wonderful person right
here in concord that has caught
as kraut
chili and actually uh
even cheese whiz
so is that in between the two streets
there the little right oh yeah right on
yeah
and
she does a great job
so
i i like my hot dog with
onions on it
you cannot get right now
according to what i understand fresh
vegetables and i don't know whether your
onions are sauteed or not well i like
them i like them raw raw yeah i like raw
i don't know you can't if i want if i
want the saute that would i wanted steak
and cheese for that but
i just want him raw on my hot dog
no ketchup from pittsburgh worked in
philadelphia for many years and got
steak and cheese
um
that is my understanding of the state
department
rules and regulations that's crazy okay
good representative
thank you for taking my question um
which is do you think it's problematic
if somebody you mentioned i believe you
said making chili at home and then
bringing it in
did you say that i did not say that i
said if they buy it pre-made okay if
they buy it pre-made but i i think that
that should be an option
follow-up if they excuse me let me just
i'm sorry if they do it at home
and maybe they have to have their home
inspected but a three-based sink at home
to make chili
it's a little bizarre follow-up for the
question question yeah i i think that
might be problematic if it's not a
certified safe served kitchen i mean
that's the law for um caters and just
follow up this is just in the in the
category of stupid
minutia um it says frankfurters and
pre-cooked sausages of frankfurter
because i look this up is actually
i mean if you talk about a hot dog a hot
dog is not a sausage a frankfurter is
but a hot dog isn't
i believe the state has now
in their present rules and correct me if
i'm wrong allowed
sausages and
a dog
and i can't define what hot dog is
well you know it's kind of weird because
you know you have a hot dog that's got
pork and beef in it
so
what what's the difference between a hot
dog and a sausage
it's all got the natural natural casing
or whether
i i can't tell you that representative
hot dog is pre-cooked a hot dog is made
of of by meat by-products by definition
whereas a sauce it's different for a
sausage it's more natural
i'm just telling you what what what i
what was not what i researched
you know you learned something new every
day
representative herbert has a question
for
representative wolf um
would you believe um
i i would like to have hot dog stands
but i don't see any around i don't know
why
yeah
just go down the street here on main
street between
right next to them there's one there and
following me
is and you will get copies of this
sun uppy dogs which is a place that
sells
hot dogs that is inspected and licensed
by the state
and has a uh five bay serving dish
etcetera
so you're gonna get you're gonna get
that that's a big cart
well it's not a very big carpet
yeah it's good sales okay
any more questions for representative
what license does the hot dog stand have
here on
in concord
he has to get a license from the state
of new hampshire health and human
services
is it the same license i don't know
we'll have to find out
i i believe the
department i don't have a card
kobe from the state i'm sure is going to
testify behind me and she can answer
that i didn't realize i was following
the big production of the food trucks i
just had a simple little house we are
learning more about how to get
this is a whole new fast food world
all right all right thank you very much
anything else
um okay
peter is going to testify
oh wait here it is
i found it way over here okay
these best people just give the cards to
me i guess all right colleen says
i'm in a panic
good afternoon chairman hunt and thank
you members of the committee uh so i am
here to
provide some information with regard to
this bill and i can also
uh in light of the previous bill
explain some differences that might help
set the set the stage for this one so
what we were talking about before is a
food truck and we look at those a little
bit differently than a push cart a push
cart it is
the license fee is less money it has
much less requirements a food truck
that's licensed by the state would be
required to have either a three-base
sink and a hand sink on board or in
commercial refrigeration or they'd have
to work in tangent with a commercial
kitchen in order to have those abilities
push carts as it stands they have very
minimal requirements they're just
required to keep foods at the proper
temperature control whether it be a
cooler with ice in some instances but in
that for that reason we we're very
restrictive on the types of foods that
they can offer they can offer only
pre-packaged foods or
what's also allowable as is frankfurters
and i um it's been that way since i've
been with the department just the
allowance of frankfurters and i
as i understand the history of that it's
because if you start allowing sausages
then the tendency would be to have
things like peppers and onions and
really why it's been so restrictive is
because we don't want
cooking in the outdoors the push carts
aren't enclosed they're open to the
elements so you have dust debris
open
open cooking situations and also you the
tendency would be to use maybe a home
kitchen to support that
and that's why we've been very
restrictive on the types of condiments
or and haven't allowed things such as
sauerkraut or chili because we wouldn't
know if it's coming from a can or if
somebody's preparing it in their home
which again isn't set up to cool foods
properly keep them at proper
temperatures it's subject to everything
that's in a home kitchen whether it's
you know children pets so forth is that
it's very different standards than what
a commercial kitchen is
so um example of the the hot dog cart
that's in concord that would be licensed
by the city and many of the cities they
require a commissary relationship for
these push cart situations so we don't
require that and that's why we try to
keep very
types of foods minimal
there have been instances where we've
issued a variance one of the ski
mountains last year came to us because
they wanted to offer sausages
because they were trying to keep folks
outside and not inside due to the
pandemic so we did grant a variance
they're working in conjunction with the
commercial kitchen on site so as long as
they can demonstrate that they have a
commercial kitchen they can make those
foods safely there have been instances
where we've offered offered of a
variance to that the push cart
regulation but you know certainly for
the reasons that um
that we don't require from to the
initial licensing requirements are very
minimal for push carts that's why we've
really been restrictive on the types of
foods that are allowed
and i'm happy to answer any questions
the committee has representative johnson
so you're saying that if
they wanted to offer fresh onions
mr cheer loves his onions
if they got it from like they say a
prepackaged local farm stand
and they offered it
on their push cart they could do that
but they can't buy the onion in the
local store chop it up and put it on his
cart
that's what we're we're trying to
restrict the amount of food prep because
again they if they don't have a
relationship with a commercial kitchen
they're either doing it outside or
they're doing it in in their home
kitchen but they so
they could go to like a local farm stand
who usually has a deli or some type of
thing where they have a regular kitchen
they could buy the prepackaged
they could buy like the onions and
sauerkraut from the they
they could cur they could buy like a
great little prepackaged cup
um
from another vendor
hannaford's has
the onions already chopped
and wrapped
right they could buy a pre-packaged i
they could buy a pre-packaged onion to
offer there
yes
okay
uh representative
just a quick uh question um
this is a experience that i've had a
small food truck hot dogs inside the
food truck
very tiny
uh i asked for relish or whatever it was
condiments on my hot dog that i was
buying through the window
and the man said i am not i'm not
allowed by the state to put this on your
hot dog but outside the window was a
whole array of different things
was he telling me something
was he misunderstanding the law or was
he not allowed to
put the condiments on my on my hot dog
i i'm not quite sure in that instance
what he would have been doing wrong by
preparing it for for you
it sounds like he had a separate table
is what you're saying
and says i can't put it on you but you
see that table over there
he made it sound like it was illegal for
him to to serve it that's the way i
interpret it
but was it do was it his table full of
onions and peppers it was it was
literally within arm reach from him it
was just outside the window
there's a difference between serving it
and having it available
not in their mind your mind is it
so we we wouldn't preclude him from some
from putting it on him himself it might
have been maybe a misunderstanding or
maybe his decision didn't he didn't want
it didn't want to take that
responsibility
well but let's again we're talking about
a push cart okay and he chopped up the
onions at home
and he puts it on a table that's six
feet away from him
well it's just saying if he if he had he
can't put it on himself because he
chopped the onions up at home oh i see
he's trying to get around it exactly by
saying this he didn't put it on there
it's over there you can go get it he's
not selling it i would say that was
illegal right i mean that would i would
say
if it's yeah that sounds like it would
that air that would still be under his
control and part of his
food establishment so i would say he
wouldn't be allowed to do that
okay so so let me get this right so as
long as they're getting the onions
chopped up
from hannafords
in a pre-package
and getting
ormel's chili
in a can
is he allowed to heat that chili up so
we would allow the thing the
pre-packaged because there's not any
prep doing what happening with those
onions right but the chili part of it
that's
that would wouldn't allow as it stands
you can't have a chili dough because
it's considered food preparation and so
and it it just it lends itself to it
it's it's
leads itself to other things because you
know what happens at the end of the day
and he doesn't want to throw that chili
out so where does he bring it home he
brings it home to his um he brings it to
his refrigerator or how does he cleaning
it he's cleaning it he's got to clean
that pan where is that happening and
right now as i mentioned we have very
minimal requirements for we don't
require them to have sinks on board
so that's why we've been very
restrictive to the types of menu items
that they could that they could offer
because they're not required to have
them on board or work with a commercial
kitchen
representative johnson
thank you for taking my so again kind of
going back to the onion thing they could
go and then purchase chili from
somebody else who has the commercial
kitchen
get the pre-made chili from another
local vendor
and serve it that way
but he can't make the chili and serve it
but he could get it pre-packaged from a
local restaurant and serve it so he goes
to a restaurant and says oh we'll take a
gallon of chili
so again that become that would become a
little bit more complicated because we
would look to how they would still have
to dispense that chili and unless they
were pre-packaging it into individual
containers but then they'd have to keep
it warm i think there would be a little
bit more
difficulty in doing a chili situation
because likely they're getting a a
container they're going to have to keep
that hot they're going to have to ladle
that out they're going to have to clean
all of those things at the end of the
day a chili is a little bit different
animal than than the cut onions in the
package how many states you think are as
strict as as we are about
this well i would say i sure feel like
i've had a chili dog somewhere a long
way but maybe not
i would say that so again just going
back to we we have very minimal
requirements so if i got that we could
we could have them work with a
commissary kitchen and allow these
things to happen um as do many of the
self-inspecting but currently we don't
require as a condition to get a license
them to have an agreement with a
commissary kitchen
and and we have and as
we have let places we have issued
variances to to this rule if they can
show that they do have a commissary
license to to work with
so right because you mentioned the
commissary license earlier so and i
never heard that before uh i'm learning
so much today but
the comments are licensed how much is
that license
so it would they'd have to have they'd
have to have an agreement with the one
either the
commissary could they might not need a
license there if the commissary is doing
everything before the commissary is the
restaurant next door
so the restaurant next door is fully
licensed restaurant they could get their
chili from there
they could have an agreement with them
that that commissary is taking
responsibility for the cleanup and the
food preparation if they want to
actually do food preparation there if
they want to make their own wrap
sandwiches or their own chili then
they'd have to have a license at that
restaurant but if they if the restaurant
is doing it's providing the chili for
them providing the chili providing the
cleanup we wouldn't require a license we
would just require proof that the other
place is licensed and that they have
this agreement so there's no connoisseur
there's no actual license them doing
it's just that they're already licensed
a restaurant so he just has to
show
some written agreement
that they have with
some restaurant
that they that
they
that restaurant will take care of the
cleanup and everything like that so
should we just put that in the statute
so people see that and know that that's
true
so
again we do we have um had this happen
with a variance but if they're if you
know i i i guess if there needs to be
clarity that
um around this that that's a
possibility i mean i want a chili dog
sometimes
okay representative abel
yes thank you and thank you for
testifying
uh pardon me if if you uh have said this
before but does the
the excuse me does the department um
take a position on this bill or are you
neutral or what well we are we have cons
definitely have concerns um you know as
i've provided some written testimony
there as an example
something is you might think as simple
as a cheese sauce that there have been
outbreaks of botulism outbreak that
actually sickened 10 people and killed
another in california in recent years
because
if these pla if these materials aren't
cleaned properly um that there there
could be outbreaks associated with them
so we definitely have concerns with the
bill as written be unless we could again
allow allow for those relationships that
they're at least going to a commercial
kitchen
at the end of the day to
either do the food preparation and clean
up
representative
thank you i think there's some
misunderstanding on the onions um for
example if i went to hannaford's and
bought a
little little tray of onions and i
scooped it out for each hot dog that
wouldn't work but if i had no she said
it would work that would be legal no i
think it has to be a single unit like
the ketchup and the mustard in a single
unit the chili could be in a single unit
and the onions have to be in a single
unit i couldn't buy six ounces of onions
and
teaspoon them out every time somebody
wants onions on their dough can you
clarify that because i was thinking
differently
do you know what we're talking about
it's it's you know in hannaford's it's
in between their vegetables and their
lettuce and they have these pre-made
things where you can get
purple you know they get the you know
the purple onion and they have the
yellow onion it's already
pre-chopped it's packaged it's sealed
but it's not individual it's
it's going to have
10 servings in it
so
we would like to see those be like
individually packaged because again
we're trying to minimize minimalize the
open food and the dispensing of food is
is knowing that these are carts are very
um
they're open to the air and there isn't
those supporting
supporting
services with clean up that to try to
keep the
other activities as minimal as possible
okay so it had to be an individual
survey package yes and unfortunately uh
being from pittsburgh and heinz
they actually do have that product with
onions
i haven't seen it very often but i know
it does exist
so okay
representation
thank you mr chairman
under the old adages when in rome do as
the romans do or if you can't
if you can't beat them join them i'm
gonna weigh in with a question um about
sauerkraut
uh
it's my turn
so so i understand if i if i buy a
package of sauerkraut i run a food cart
uh or a push cart or whatever and i buy
a package of sauerkraut at hannaford's
then i can serve the sauerkraut
um
or i can't serve the sauerkraut
unless it's an individual serving
package right we're asking that they
would be preaching it's pre-packaged
sauerkraut we're out of a can yes okay
that's fine yes okay now we come to the
end of the day but it has to be
individual serving
i've never seen individual servings of
sauerkraut
excuse me are you talking so are you
talking about individual servings of
sauerkraut yes individuals oh okay so
we're not talking about a package of
sauerkraut that i that i empty into a
warming tray and then i put that on the
hot dogs for the customers no they have
to be individual
have you ever seen an individual packet
of sauerkraut
therefore made it impossible for people
to to per have sauerkraut on their hot
dogs in the state of new hampshire
how could that be done
i'm very concerned because i love
sauerkraut and i i'm concerned about
government regulations
basically the point is you can do it
if
a
you have an agreement with some other
restaurant
who is going to provide you that
sauerkraut properly heated and they will
clean it at the end of the day when
you're finished with it who will
the restaurant the restaurant will clean
the sauerkraut clean the pot that you
put it in and whatever they will what
about the leftover sauerkraut it goes
back to the restaurant you would get you
would take it back to them and then they
have their own and then they really
didn't send it to me the next day and
theoretically they'll they're
responsible to make sure that it is safe
to be served the following day thank you
for clarifying that
okay
are you all set represented terry
yes i got my sauerkraut question
okay representative not german but i
like south korea
thank you for your testimony um i'm
going to reference probably the largest
push cart city in the world new york
city
are you aware of the rules that they are
using
because i used to live in northern new
jersey i frequented a lot of push carts
in new york city
and nobody i know of ever got sick so
they must have some pretty good rules
are you aware of whether this might
explain a lot about you drawing so
so i do know i again of many of the
cities do require that commissary
relationship and then also and i do know
just i recently was in new york city
last fall and looked at one and they are
fully enclosed though they're not open
push at least the one i saw wasn't a it
was it was they do have a plastic cover
around it it was like an actual like
little
i don't know like a brick built sure
that wasn't for covid they had it all
closed it was it was um an actual
enclosed fully enclosed unit and so and
we that's again like a push cart so
certainly if you wanted to have um
sauerkrauts and
sausage and onions and and had a full
food truck that's perfectly allowable
but again those usually have a
three-based sink on board or working
with a commissary so again we're really
because and we have right now we have 30
license in the state just to give
perspective on how many push cart
situations that we have
compared to the mobile units the mobile
units we definitely have much many more
of them but
okay
so
representative bullet yeah um
i did own a restaurant for many years
and in the business plan i did some
research and researching i i knew
exactly what i needed to do as a
business owner
so my suggestion instead of this
legislation is
a food truck association which would
include the push carts so that all of
the people that own these
entities would be able to get together
and educate you know each other on how
to operate in you know in the state of
new hampshire would you believe
okay
so
the last question this legislation uh it
says um
the create look it's in rulemaking so
this whole thing about having a
conversation having a restaurant
connected to it is that in rules now is
someone is that available for someone to
see that uh now or is that a policy that
you guys have in-house so right now
their only vehicle to to expand beyond
what's currently stated in the
definition of a push cart is to do that
through a variance process and through a
variance we right we'd ask to see you
know how they're going to meet the
intent the public health intent of of
the rule which would be
to have that those supporting services
like a commissary if the wisdom in this
committee that would really want you to
create rules so that someone can figure
this out and understand is this
legislation okay for you to
if we if we if we really want to make
sure
that is that anybody who has a push cart
knows
that it might not be that bad all they
have to do is get some an arrangement
with somebody
is this
the way this uh bill is written is that
okay for you to get that done if we
could work through that in rule yes that
would be acceptable okay okay
thank you very much as always
okay peter huxta
how do you pronounce your your last name
it's hook straw hook straw it's going to
say it's like h-o-o
here we are doing hawkers and peddlers
okay
so a good afternoon everyone uh thank
you committee for allowing me to testify
briefly my name is peter huckstra and i
am from sunapee new hampshire
i own sunapee harbor dogs
i am 64 years old and i always dreamt of
owning a hot dog stand
and by golly i did it last summer
and i'll be able to answer some of your
questions about condiments uh as we kind
of go along here if you're interested
um
we operate our hours are
typically this year will be from
mother's day through columbus day on the
weekends
we're right in the harbor
we have a push cart license we also
pay our rooms and meals tax
i support the bill because i had many
many many people like
a representative here ask me if i could
sell put chili
and sauerkraut on the hot dog
so to answer your question sir about
sauerkraut
you can buy small little packages of
that costs about 75 cents a piece
and i included that in my three dollar
hot dog charge this year because i felt
it was appropriate that people were able
to get sauerkraut
on the hot dog so that was the only way
i was able to do it to your question
about onions we did buy heinz onions
that were pre-packaged
and those were also included and those
were about 30 cents each
and that was part of the hot dog cost
you charge extra for these things no i
didn't charge extra at all
so
it was a great summer
and i learned a lot and i can't wait to
open up again this next mother's day
so i'm here to answer a few questions
everything we serve is precooked
it all gets cleaned there's pictures you
can see that you're past i passed around
of the hot dog cart itself
um
pretty pretty pimped out and it doesn't
look like it got a lot a lot of stuff
here that looks like a sink is that a so
we have four sinks on our hot dog cart
so when that
doesn't cover you for washing your
dishes and it does not because it
doesn't it's not a commerce it's not a
registered kitchen
okay
cool any questions yes yeah um thank you
mr chair thank you for taking the
question did you do uh research um or
did you um
uh get information from the health
department regarding a commissary if you
do partner up with the commissary that
may be what
you would need
i did get information from the
department about a commissary
relationship
i'm quite frankly not interested in that
simply because i don't think any of the
kitchens in town who are already upset
that i opened up a hot dog right your
competition to them are going to extend
the good will
to allow me to use their kitchens
to be
in competition with them
just it simply it won't happen in santa
fe but maybe somewhere else
so i didn't understand this entire
um
the restrictions on this license
and up until i understood it i was ready
to sell everything
and it simplified my menu dramatically
so we served hot dogs with ketchup
mustard relish
onions packages
sauerkraut packages
that was it
and we did we had we had a fabulous
summer
but i'll bet two-thirds of the people
asked me if i could put something else
on my hot dog or their hot dog
and a representative was one of those
yeah
mr jay yes represent terry
so with the sauerkraut in the packets
yeah
were you able to heat the sauerkraut or
did you have to serve the packets cold
the
people opened the customers open the
package themselves yes and put it on so
my hot dog cart did not put condiments
on the hot dogs for anybody
i see i didn't know them well the same
as him right so it was cold sauerkraut
it was room temperature room temperature
yes okay a little warm up you roll the
hot dog around yeah sometimes
sauerkraut's always better
it was sometimes warm got it thank you
representative
yes here's my question given the rules
that we just heard about if you had an
enclosure over your hot dog stand would
there be would you still would you then
be able to sell these things because
there wouldn't be the concern about the
dust and and the and the the other
things no
no
if it was completely enclosed
i would have to be inside of
an enclosure
serving out of a window in order to do
this
yes that would be fine okay that's
pretty cool but that's not my hot dog
stand okay
all right hello representative
yes
thank you so much for coming um
so you support the bill and and feel
that if rules were clearer
better
expressed
by the department that others besides
you could
could uh do exactly what you're doing
now
uh is that is that correct
well in light of hearing there's only 30
push carts in our state yeah
uh absolutely
and it makes the further question
follow-up and now i'm forgetting what it
is so all right forget the uh
okay thank you um
and this is for you and uh
representative
i the problem of this bill the way it's
written is that you're giving it to the
department to make rules
which doesn't necessarily mean
you're going to like the rule that they
come up with
because they might just come back they
just might turn this rule into
you need to have the commissary
i'm just warning you
it's the cost of doing business
you gotta factor that in
right you gotta have a sign saying
new hampshire's department of health and
human services don't recommend you
buying from this car
so if i could add just one one more
quick thing
every day
we come to the hot dog cart with
pre-cooked hot dogs okay
and with those hot dogs we bring along
washed sanitized
tongs to pick them up
okay
any of what we're talking about here is
going to be treated exactly the same way
because it's already all pre-cooked
everything is going to get i clean the
pans just like you see them
every single day
this is
if i had a grill
and i had raw beef
and i was trying to cook those
that is a different story i totally
understand that
but everything on this cart
is completely precooked
and i'll leave it out there
representative johnson
so let me end this yes thank you for
letting me ask my question
so you're telling me that
the hot dogs that you
sell in your hot dog stand
are already pre-cooked when you bring
them
but you can't do the same thing with an
onion
right
that makes no sense
yeah i don't want cooked onions i want
raw onions
you can have you it makes no sense
well thank you you know where this was
this was an interesting day today
thank you very much thank you very much
representative you want to wrap this one
up
yes thank you for the opportunity this
sounds like the second bill
that i might have screwed up
in submitting
[Music]
i think the committee
maybe should
itl this if the department is going to
make rules that are so cumbersome that
it kills the hot dog industry
and i have no control over it as you
suggested mr chairman
so
we have a good relationship with the
department we'll see if we can find
find a way to
get this to be
palatable thank you very much
thank you awesome
in our pre-cooked sausage okay um
amber found a commissary
so uh
the the blue sheet we have one person uh
zephan wood
from pembroke new hampshire and
is in support of the bill
and well that will close the public
hearing
yeah oh yeah no problem
oh no no no that's no then you click on
something and they say oh no that's just
the picture that's what he said
but there are actually
this is better than a lot of other stuff
that other committees do
at least it's something new and
different each day i'm learning about
things like that
before you open
i mean that's it here i mean look at
this thing i mean it's enclosed and
if you're going to do it that that gets
you around a lot of the stuff well you
know what it is
the prebase thing needs to be deep
enough to wash that chili pot and if
it's not you can't serve chicken
it's all about this thing but this would
but if you have other possibilities
i mean
i may not know too much about bitcoin
but i know all about the restaurant
um
okay
but that's what i think
he's
uh
so
inspection
um
is
thank you for your
that expertise
is
um
but again
oh
is
um
oh
it's very frustrating
is
foreign
we'll open up the public hearing on 1043
and hear from the sponsor uh judy
it runs through duty
i get myself situated here
good afternoon chairman hunt
and all the members of the commerce
committee i've never come to see your
committee hi
so i'm here today
to present my bill uh hb 10 oh by for
the record this is uh representative
judy aaron and i represent sullivan
county district seven which is awkward
goshen langdon lumpster and washington
and so i uh have this bill hb 1043
and i know everybody is a fan of study
bills but uh
in light of that
i wanted to say that i had had over the
summer and
probably before then to
numerous complaints from local small
businesses regarding food safety rules
that they must adhere to
the rules can be as you've heard in
previous testimony the rules have been
can be confusing
illogical and sometimes costly to our
constituents
i feel that it's necessary that we take
a deep dive into these issues facing our
small businesses that sell food
so this study committee should study
number one state and local regulations
including food licensing and food safety
rules applicable to small businesses
that sell food
number two the problems caused by the
current food safety rules for small
businesses
and number three whether food safety
rules can be simplified and or modified
for small businesses that sell food
and number four
to identify what future legislative
actions if any are necessary to address
the problems faced by small businesses
that sell food in order to comply with
current state and local
requirements
and i believe there's federal
requirements involved in this too
but anyway here are a few examples of
what people have told me about the rules
they must follow so
and and for sure these businessmen don't
want to poison their customers
they are very careful and conscientious
they want to do the right thing they
want to make sure their food that
they're selling is safe
but sometimes these food safety rules
simply don't make any sense
so for instance i
did know of i did meet a hot dog vendor
this past summer and she complained to
me
again that she could put jarred cut up
onions here we go with the onions
on her customers hot dog but if she cut
up an onion herself on the food prep
area of her cart
which she keeps spotless
then she would be required to have a
restaurant license
and a restaurant license is also as we
all know an involved and costly endeavor
i know another business that has a food
truck
they were unable to hook up a food grade
hose to a clean drinking water source
from a store structure
at allison's in walpole and instead
they were told they could only use water
from containers in their own food truck
trucking around their own water was dick
ridiculous it took up very valuable
space in their food truck and restricted
their water use
and the water would have been just as
safe and drinkable from their hose
hookup
another constituent who's a dairy farmer
said to me
that they wanted to get a small
pasteurizer and pasteurize their milk
and make butter soft soft cheeses
puddings yogurt kefir and creams
and they were told they needed a
commercial chick kitchen with a three
basin to do that
but yet if they had a homestead license
they could do that without a three base
sink
so that kind of doesn't make any sense
people are not allowed to put a
commercial kitchen in their home at
least that's what i'm told
yet you can still bake things in your
regular kitchen and label it exempt from
new hampshire licenses
i'm also going to note that some people
told me today that they couldn't come
today or they wouldn't come today
because to testify because they were
afraid
to come and testify for fear of reprisal
from state agencies
and i'd say that's indicative of a
problem
people didn't want to come here and then
say something and then have an inspector
show up at their doorstep tomorrow
so i believe this study bill is one
that's really needed
we really should as a legislature take a
good hard look at these rules and see
where some can be eliminated simplified
clarified
and just basically taken a look at for
our small businesses
i'm told that some of these rules even
will make people abandon their dreams of
starting a business because they end up
being so costly to implement
and i hope that you'll pass this bill
out of your committee with an otp
recommendation and start the process of
really looking at what we're asking
are small businesses that sell food or
want to sell food what they should
you know how they should do things
um
i mean given the testimony that we heard
earlier
it it just
really
underscores
the reason the the the idea that
there are some things that don't seem to
make sense and some things that we
really need to
take a look at and see
how people are doing it why they're
doing it why the state is requesting
them to do it
i mean there may be very very good
reasons why things are being done or
asked to be done a certain way
but i think we really need need to take
a look and and see what the differences
are
between these different licenses
and
how people are are being
asked to adhere to these rules
so
with that i'd be happy to take any
questions
representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question judy
uh representative um i love this bill
i think we can get get rid of the other
two bills
because this is exactly what we need to
do
um
would you believe but i also wanted to
mention that
study committees i mean
the your side of the aisle does not want
study committees so why are you
presenting a bill for a study committee
i like the idea but
yeah well you know i think sometimes
study committees are really warranted we
have to do them i think we have to you
know
take a deep dive into what we are what
we have put in place
in the in the statutes
and and
just step back and take a look and see
how how these are working or not working
i mean the fact that we only have 30
vendors or street hot dog vendors or
whatever the cart vendors are in the
whole entire state of new hampshire
that
that points to me that there is an issue
of uh
well maybe the rules
are cost prohibitive i don't know i mean
that's what we should look at hey
thank you
barlett thank you mr chair
um so you want to take a deep dive and
so if this gets passed through the house
by the end of february then it goes to
the senate
gets passed to the senate sometime in
april you only have five people doing
this and it only applies to small
businesses but there's no definition of
what a small business is
okay
and you want to
you want to address everything from
poultry to dairy to
food prep
and and you want to get this all out of
committee during a campaign year i mean
is this really realistic to be able to
get
a study committee
out with that kind of a time frame
i think if there's a will we can do it
i think that
there's certainly a
time element
involved here but um i think it's
important enough
for our constituents and for our small
businesses to do this
if people feel that perhaps this is not
a year to do it because you know you
want to
go off and do some campaigning instead i
i would prefer to do something of
meaningful
work to help our constituents
and i think this this study committee is
needed
okay
thank you very much for your testimony
okay thank you
oh i would like to add one other point
too
i know that a
letter
was sent from new hampshire department
of environmental services
concerning this bill
and in this
letter to you it they had said that they
believed that this bill was related to
another bill that i had submitted
having to do with
plumbing issues and sewage and things
like that
and it's not this is not related to hbe
1312. i don't want to talk about another
bill right now
and conflate them but it is it does not
have anything to do with that bill
they're watching you
so i just wanted to make that clear i
simply want to take a look at these uh
rules
uh having to do with
you know the food
food safety rules
and we've learned today that they
they're there and they're complicated
sometimes yes
so thank you
appreciate it
okay philip do you still want to speak
okay
phillip trowelridge from
the manager of land resources
department of environmental services
that's the one the green the green uh
id that's what i was looking at
good afternoon
all right
i'm just passing around copies of the
letter
so
good afternoon chairman hunt and members
of the committee thank you for this
opportunity to testify
for the record my name is phillip
trobridge i'm the manner of manager of
the land resource management programs at
new hampshire des
and
part of that program is the subsurface
systems bureau which deals with septic
system permitting
and
so i'm here today to testify in support
of this bill
the bill seeks
to have a study committee related to
food safety and licensing regulations
des is mentioned in the bill
because some of the des regulations
related to
septic systems and water supply are
cross-referenced in the food safety
regulations um the department would be
happy to participate in the study
committee uh we recognize that these
things are complicated and we are always
looking for ways to streamline and
modernize regulations and reduce the
regulatory burden on our
on the people of the state
and as representative erin mentioned uh
in our in our letter we did a cross
reference to house bill 1312 which is
related to
plumbing code issues i understand her
point uh directly that she wants this
bill to be focused on food safety
because of the cross referencing that we
have
we it pulls in some of our regulations
related to water supply and wastewater
so it might be appropriate to
if you really want this just to focus on
food safety we might have to
say something to exempt these other
aspects related to food service
licensing
so you know with that i mean i just want
to thank you all for the opportunity to
testify and i'm happy to take any
questions
uh just for a lark um
grease when they're when they under the
oil when they did the for the fryers
yeah
so
i assume
somebody needs to come and take it away
that you can't dump it into your septic
system and yes so do you regulate that
those operator or whatever what happened
at disposal of that that grease
yes we have regulations on that for sure
um so it's it's a got a couple of issues
because um the like the requirements are
to
to remove the grease you can't pour it
down the drain and if you're yeah for us
when dealing with septic systems the
increased interceptors are there to
protect the septic system from being
basically just you know
becoming effective and then there's a
secondary issue that if the septage
that's caught in a septic tank is
becomes contaminated with grease
then the septage haulers are taking this
material to a wastewater treatment plant
and sometimes the plant won't accept it
yeah they're awful
and or
you know if the plant does accept it it
can foul the plant so there's a lot of
good reasons to manage grease well and
there's some great uh best management
practices on that that businesses can
follow
it's it's complicated but there there's
regular people out there that come and
take this from restaurants and yeah
absolutely
right they burn it right you can they
don't they burn it to make energy out of
it yeah there's one company that accepts
it for biodiesel
biodiesel yeah cool yeah
so yeah there's definitely markets for
it and so there's a process but you know
that's this is we're kind of getting
into the material for house bill 1312
right
and
we just if there's going to be a study
committee um and it's covering some of
these complicated issues we just think
maybe these two committees could or we
will not be doing this now yeah then
that's fine
all right we if you were here earlier
you can see we have got our hands full
with just the two that we well two known
problems we really got
before we could start looking for
looking for problems so i i have to say
it was
we've got to get our sauerkraut heated
right it was a very interesting
conversation and it made me very hungry
[Laughter]
all right well thank you very much for
coming all right thank you anybody have
any questions for mr albert city none
thank you very much does anybody else
would like to testify on
house bill
uh the
blue sheet the mail-in internet is
11 people in support and one person to
post
with that i will close the public
hearing
and see you all next wednesday so
remember
the subcommittees are at nine o'clock
now on on wednesday
and then uh at 1 15 1 15 when we get
back from lunch i hope to uh exec all of
all the eight the eight uh early bills
we don't have to oh yeah other
announcement
very important other announcement
chrissy you might want to hear this one
because 1502 that we have removed
the uh
the separate division
the speaker has waived us sending it to
a second committee so we don't have to
do crypto too quickly
we can be more cryptic with our crypto
if we um
i don't think
right
we want to take away the argument that
in terms of this is moving too fast
yes yes
so i'm intending on putting in an
amendment to this bill okay so that it
limits it to food trucks carts homestead
but we're already doing those issues now
we already have two bills of doing that
yeah
okay we're already doing it
no we don't need to say we know what the
problems are we just spent an hour
and a half learning with the problem
we know the problem now no it's the